Hai cái in.
Hôm trước mình có ra bài tập về nhà là
bài tập xác định phạm vi đề xuất.
Bác hồi tất cả tại do đây là cái bước đầu
tiên để thực hiện đồ án môn học của mình.
Và cũng như là xác định cái dự án phần
mềm mình dự kiến làm trong cái phần bài
thực hành.
Nên nó là cái phần quan trọng nhất để.
Kem tiếp tục thực hiện,
nếu mà mình chọn cái giai đoạn này,
mình xác định phạm vi đề xuất của mình có
vấn đề thì nó có thể dẫn đến cái bài đồ
án với cái bài tình hình của mình.
Nó sẽ bị sai hướng theo.
Nên cái phần bài tập này đã bài tập quan
trọng và cô sẽ sửa hết cho tất cả các
nhóm.
Các em lát hồi mình.
Mà trao đổi với nhau và mở sẵn vai cái
bài tập,
cái yêu cầu của mình gồm có cái khảo sát
tổng quan và sản phẩm đầu ra của mình là
một trang nêu rõ về đầu tư năng lực.
Mình đầu tư năng lực nào cho đối tượng
nào là nhân viên phòng ban hay là quy
trình hoạt động và trong bao lâu thì lát
hoặc các nhóm các em sẽ trình bày cái dự
kiến phạm vi đề xuất mà mình thực hiện
trong cái bài đầu ấy du học.
Trước là một trang này,
sau đó giới thiệu về các cái tài liệu
khảo sát hay là các tài liệu tụi em tham
khảo dùng cho cái phần đăng ký đồ án môn
học cũng như thực hành của mình luôn á
các em.
Chắc cái này nằm trong thời gian để cho
các em chuẩn bị và các bạn khác vào sơ đủ.
Thì tới cô cho các em chuẩn bị nhiều hơn
một chút, tới 18 giờ 45 ha.
8 giờ 145, mình sẽ bắt đầu sửa bài.
Nếu có nhóm mà xung phong thì cô sẽ kêu
theo cái nhóm sông hôm trước cho đến hết,
còn không là theo thứ tự ha.
Nói chung là nhóm nào cũng phải trình bày
chỉ là theo thứ tự khác nhau thôi.
Rồi nhóm 11 bác có cái nhà,
nhóm 11 mình bắt đầu đi các em.
Dạ vâng ạ
Và cô cho em hỏi là em xem màn hình không
biết cô có thấy chưa?
Rồi được rồi thấy rồi.
Dạ, dạ vâng,
em chào cô và các anh chị và các bạn thì
em tên là Thiện thì hôm nay em xin phép
đại diện cho nhóm 11 trình bày về phần
cái project Corp cũng như là bài tập tuần
thứ 3 của môn học cơ sở hạ tầng công nghệ
thông tin thì đối với.
Tập này thì nhóm em thực hiện gồm 2 phần
theo đúng cái yêu cầu của cô đưa ra,
đó là về ý tưởng đầu tư cơ sở hạ tầng
công nghệ thông tin cho cái đồ án môn học
cũng như là từ đó thì phát triển các ý
tưởng về phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới
cho phần thực hành.
Song song đó thì nhóm cũng thực hiện phân
tích các phần danh sách về.
Kẹo khảo sát và tham khảo mà nhóm đã thu
thập được cho cả 2 cái phần này thì trong
phần thực hiện đồ án thì nhóm đơn vị mà
nhóm chọn để khảo sát đó là bệnh viện Đại
học Y Dược Thành phố Hồ Chí Minh viết tắt
là UMC.
Ờm đầu tiên trong phần về rjector thì đối
với các ý tưởng về đồ án môn học thì vì
sao lựa chọn UMC và nhóm đã biết được
những vì gì về cái đơn vị này á thì trước
khi nói tới cái việc đầu tư gì thì nhóm
sinh tóm tắt?
Rất nhanh về cái bối cảnh của JMC cũng
như là phần này thì nhóm sẽ đã khảo sát
kỹ và cũng sẽ trình bày chi tiết nguồn ở
phần thứ 2,
GMC là bệnh viện đại học bây giờ thành
phố Hồ Chí Minh là bệnh viện công lập
hạng nhất và nó là thuộc mô hình trường
viện nó hình thành trong năm 1994 và.
Chính thức thành lập vào năm 2001 hiện
tại thì nó có 3 cơ sở chính,
nó có 3 cơ sở và với quy mô khoảng 1.
000 giường bệnh về các cơ cấu tổ chức
theo nhóm tìm hiểu và khảo khảo sát được
thì nó khá là phân tán với lại 15 phòng
và trung tâm chức năng.
Ba trung tâm chuyên sâu vào cuốn.
À, thấy ngơi,
em thử tắt xe lại như cái đường truyền
mạng của em nó yếu quá nên cái chữ cái độ
phân giải bị mờ á.
Dạ dạ vâng.
Khi đường chính là mình phấn to lên một
tí.
Dạ dạ.
Cái này không biết cho trên đường truyền
hay là lỗi bên tiên mà thường cái đó là
do lỗi đường truyền yếu nó hay bị vậy.
Dạ, vâng ạ.
nhạc.
Ủa sao lúc đầu nó thiệt lúc đầu nó rõ rồi
xong nó lại mờ ta.
Trẻ em thử lại đang nữa nhé cô.
Hay là để em xem full màn hình.
Lúc mới xe thì nó rõ, xong rồi nó lại mờ.
Không biết gì nó có rõ hơn không cô?
Đà Lạt anh đang góp.
Dạ.
Nó giận mờ vậy em ơi,
hay là mình mình nói thôi một bạn bạn nào
khác trong nhóm của mình share thử được
không?
Dạ vậy thì em hỏi mấy bạn?
Cái này là chắc là do cái đường truyền
của bên em tối nó hơi yếu nên cái bị mờ.
Dạ dạ vâng.
Dạ vậy để em nhờ bạn Khánh xe cô chờ giúp
em khoảng 1 phút nha cô để bạn bạn setup
Ok
lại cái file dạ.
Em cảm ơn cô với lại mọi người.
Bạn Khánh xem hình thấy rõ tác dụng.
Cô cô để một xíu nha, em vô nhầm file.
Dạ rồi, em tiếp tục trình bày cô nha.
Ok em thấy rõ luôn.
Dạ dạ vâng ạ,
em tiếp tục về phần cái cơ cấu tổ chức mà
nhóm đã tìm hiểu và khảo sát được thì cái
cơ cấu tổ chức của GMC thì nó khá là phân
tán với lại 15 phòng và trung tâm chức
năng.
Trong đó thì có 3 trung tâm chuyên sâu,
42 khoa chuyên môn và khoảng.
À theo số liệu nhóm cập nhật được từ
trang web chính của bệnh viện là cập nhật
lần cuối vào năm 20 cuối năm 2024 là nhân
sự khoảng 4.
219 người đối với quy trình khám chữa
bệnh thì nó đi qua nhiều bước.
Tuy nhiên thì mỗi bước chạm vào một cái
hệ thống nghiệp vụ khác nhau như là cái.
Hệ thống nghiệp vụ chính là SIS,
hệ thống hệ thống về.
Xét nghiệm và trả kết quả xét nghiệm EES
và các hệ thống về lưu trữ hình ảnh,
chẩn đoán hình ảnh VACS thì cũng như là
các hệ thống khác như là hệ thống dược,
hệ thống về tài chính và bảo hiểm y tế
thì tất cả các hệ thống này nó đi qua
những cái quy trình và hệ thống nghiệp vụ
khác nhau.
Thì từ những cái điều đó mà nhóm khám
khám phá ra được sau khi tiến hành các
cái khảo sát thì cái vấn đề mà nhóm phát
hiện được đó là với cái quy mô và các cái
cơ cấu như vậy thì nhóm nhận ra 2 điểm
nghẽn lặp lại nhiều lần trong những cái
lần mà nhóm thực hiện khảo sát đối với
bệnh viện đại học y dược thành phố Hồ Chí
Minh.
Đó là về phân mảnh hệ thống và phân mảnh
dữ liệu đối với cái việc phân mảnh hệ
thống thì nhiều hệ thống nghiệp vụ nó
hoạt động song song trên 3 cơ sở nhưng mà
nó chưa có một cái nền tảng kết nói chung.
Nếu mà để point-boint thì nó sẽ ngày càng
phức tạp hơn về phân mảnh dữ liệu thì cái
dữ liệu phát sinh liên tục với.
Các quy mô hàng triệu lượt khách trên năm
thì như mọi người cũng có thể biết Bệnh
viện Đại học Yuri thành phố Hồ Chí Minh
là một trong những bệnh viện tuyến cuối
tuyến trung ương ở khu vực phía Nam này,
cho nên là cái khối lượng mà bệnh nhân đổ
về để khám chữa bệnh thì ngày càng đông
và hiện tại đang rất rất là đông nên
những.
Cái nhu cầu về báo cáo và thống kê nó lại
còn dồn vào một số cái thời điểm nhất
định như là cuối ngày hoặc là cuối tháng,
hoặc là những cái kỳ báo cáo đặc biệt thì
như vậy thì nếu như cái dữ liệu này nó
vẫn nằm rời rạc thì cái việc tổng hợp báo
cáo nó sẽ chậm thủ công và nó sẽ có nhiều
rủi ro và cũng như là chưa có.
Hoạt động tốt,
vì vậy mà nhóm mới thực hiện đề xuất đầu
tư 2 lớp năng lực chính mà hai lớp này mà
nhóm lựa chọn đó là lớp 4 và lớp 5 đối
với lớp 4 là lớp về nền tảng ứng dụng và
tích hợp thì cái lớp này nó sẽ giải quyết
được trực tiếp cái vấn đề về phân mảnh hệ
thống.
Đó là tạo ra một cái tầng trung gian để
mà các cái hệ thống trao đổi được dữ liệu
với nhau cũng như là thay vì kết nối được,
thay vì kết nối từng cặp,
nó tràn trịch về lớp 5 là lớp nền tảng về
dữ liệu thì nó giải quyết được cái vấn đề
về phân mảnh dữ liệu đó là thu thập và tổ
chức.
Cũng như là khai thác các cái dữ liệu tập
trung,
nó phục vụ cho việc thống kê và báo cáo
quản trị.
Theo nhóm em khảo sát và nhận thấy thì
đây cũng là 2 lớp năng lực nền tảng và
đúng với lại cái phạm vi mà bước không ở
các bước không mà xác định phạm vi này
nhóm nhưng mà nhóm chưa có đi sâu vào cái
việc phát triển những cái công nghệ gì
hay là những lựa chọn những nhà cung cấp
cụ thể nào mà nhóm chỉ xét.
Định được là đầu tư năng lực gì về cái
đối tượng phục vụ mà nhóm xác định sau
khi sao cái bước khảo sát này đó là đối
tượng phục vụ trực tiếp của cái đồ án này
thực hiện đó là các hướng đến là bác sĩ
nè,
điều dưỡng nhân viên xét nghiệm và nhân
viên về chẩn đoán hình ảnh.
À nhân viên dược, nhân viên tài chính,
vân vân,
thì đây là những người tham gia trực tiếp
vào các quy trình khám chữa bệnh tại Bệnh
viện Đại học Y Dược Thành phố Hồ Chí Minh.
Về thời gian sử dụng mà nhóm dự kiến thực
hiện nhóm nhóm.
Đó là về liên tục cái thời gian sử dụng,
nó sẽ được sử dụng liên tục hàng ngày
cũng như là đặc biệt cao điểm vào cuối
ngày,
cuối tháng và cũng như vào các kỳ báo cáo
đặc biệt về việc xác định cái vòng đời
đầu tư dự kiến thì nó khoảng từ 3 đến 5
năm là định.
Hướng ban đầu mà nhóm đưa ra cũng như là
sẽ điều chỉnh mà khi nhóm thực hiện tiến
hành những cái khảo sát sâu hơn cũng như
là tìm hiểu về các cái thông tin cụ thể
hơn ở các phần tìm hiểu bài tập tiếp theo.
Ngoài ra,
bên cạnh đó thì nhóm cũng xác định về cái
ý tưởng thực hành của cái đồ án này đó là.
Là về phát triển thực hành,
đó là về phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới
thì nhóm cũng chỉ mới có việc cân nhắc
những cái ý tưởng mà nhóm đang đang nghĩ
ra nhưng mà chưa có chốt,
nhưng mà một trong những cái hướng mà
nhóm cân nhắc đó là về.
Không chọn một cái ý tưởng tách rời mà
nhóm bám sát đúng vào 2 cái lớp năng lực
vừa chọn ở đồ án môn học để mà đảm bảo
được cái tính nhất quán xuyên suốt về ý
tưởng đó là sẽ sẽ thực hiện một cái việc
phát triển phần mềm.
Thực hiện cái công nghệ mới về việc ứng
dụng tra cứu hồ sơ bệnh án liên thông thì
nó được xây dựng trên một cái tiêu chuẩn
hiện đại nhất của trong các phần mềm quản
lý bệnh viện là tiêu chuẩn SEO7.
Vì sao lựa chọn ý tưởng này thì đây là
một cái phần mềm cụ thể hóa trực tiếp lớp
4 và lớp 5.
Nó sẽ khai thác cái cơ chế tích hợp như
là API gây quay cũng như là trao đổi dữ
liệu chuẩn hóa để mà lấy cái dữ liệu tổng
hợp từ nền tảng dữ liệu và nó phục vụ
đúng cái nhu cầu tra cứu kết quả xét
nghiệm hay là chẩn đoán hình ảnh liên
khoa mà nhóm đã phát hiện trong khảo sát
quy trình.
Công nghệ mới ở đây đó là cái công nghệ
C7 thì đây là cái chuẩn trao đổi dữ liệu
y tế hiện đại nhất cũng như là được thiết
kế theo ý kiến trúc cho phép các cái hệ
thống mà em đã kể trên trong cái hệ thống
bệnh viện mà đại học y dược.
Thành phố Hồ Chí Minh sử dụng đó các hệ
thống khác nhau này,
nó sẽ như là nói dùng chung một cái ngôn
ngữ do với nhau để mà khi mà trao đổi về
cái dữ liệu của bệnh nhân thì đây cũng
chính là cái chuẩn mà nhiều bệnh viện lớn
trên thế giới đang chuyển sang dùng và
cũng phù hợp với định hướng lớp 4 mà nhóm
đã chọn.
Ở về giá trị thực tế thì ở thay vì bác sĩ
phải tra cứu thủ công qua nhiều hệ thống
thì cái ứng dụng nó sẽ cho phép xem hồ sơ
bệnh nhân liên thông từ nhiều phân hệ
trong một giao diện và nó giảm thời gian
chờ cũng như là giảm các sai sót do thiếu
thông tin.
Ở ở cái giai đoạn thực hành thì nhóm sẽ
giới hạn cái phạm vi demo ở Viettel có
thể thì nhóm nhóm những chương xác định
hoàn toàn nhưng mà có thể sẽ dựng lại ở
cái việc mô phỏng cái luồng gọi các cái
API tra cứu và hiển thị dữ liệu tổng hợp
cũng như là chưa triển khai được.
Kết hợp hợp với các hệ thống của UMC
trong cái phạm vi thực hiện của đồ án môn
học trong phần thứ 2 Khánh đã giúp mình
kéo xuống một xíu nha.
Đó là về phần danh sách những cái tài
liệu khảo sát và tham khảo mà nhóm đã
thực hiện để mà làm bài tập.
Ba lần này lần này thì nhóm cũng xin nói
về cái cách chọn nguồn cũng như là vì đây
là cái phần mà cô có cái yêu cầu là cần
phải rà soát và kiểu như là sử dụng thông
tin một cách chính xác và minh bạch từ
các cái trang chính từ các đối tượng mà
nhóm.
Lựa chọn thì cái nguyên tắc lựa chọn của
nhóm là sẽ ưu tiên tuyệt đối và các cái
nguồn chính thống như là các cái trang
chủ của bệnh viện để mà tra cứu về các
cái thông tin về lịch sử bệnh viện nè,
về giới thiệu tổng quan bệnh viện cũng
như là các cái đơn vị và các cái hướng
dẫn thủ tục khám chữa bệnh theo cái quy
trình của bệnh viện và bệnh viện đã cung
cấp.
Do khách hàng bệnh nhân được biết một
cách rất là rõ ràng trên các cái trang
web,
các cái thứ 2 trong cái quy trình sử dụng
các cái tài liệu này đó là nhóm thực hiện
đối chiếu khi mà có mâu thuẫn trong cái
quá trình mà nhóm khảo sát,
ví dụ như là cột mốc bệnh viện thành lập
đi một số.
Báo thì ghi làm 18 tháng 10 năm 2000,
nhưng chính trang của UMC thì công bố
chính thức là ngày 20 tháng 1 năm 2001
thì nhóm lựa chọn những cái thông tin này
theo có cái sự đối soát và theo cái nguồn
chính thống cho nó mang cái tính chính
xác cao nhất.
Và bên cạnh đó thì nhóm chỉ dùng những
cái nguồn thứ cấp khi mà nó có ghi ra rõ
cái ngày cập nhật như là cái số liệu về
nhân sự là 4.
219 người thì lấy từ nguồn tổng hợp nó có
ghi rõ cái cột mốc là ngày tổng hợp ngày
31 tháng 12 năm 2024.
Ờm và cuối cùng trong cái nguyên một
trong những cái nguyên tắc mà nhóm sử
dụng đó là loại bỏ cái số liệu không xác
minh được thì nhóm từng có các con số
nhân sự khác nhau nhưng mà không tìm được
nguồn nên đã bỏ hẳn và không đưa vào bài.
Ờm trong phần thực hành thì nhóm tham
khảo thêm cái phần tài liệu về kỹ thuật
chính thức của của tiêu chuẩn SE7 cũng
như là để đảm bảo được cái việc mô tả
đúng bản chất của công nghệ và không suy
diễn.
Toàn bộ tất cả các nguồn mà nhóm thực
hiện và tìm kiếm được thì nhóm cũng tiến
hành liệt.
Xe đầy đủ và có link trực tiếp ở cuối bài
nộp thì mau cô có thể xem qua và cho nhóm
thêm các cái góp ý.
Tóm lại thì về nhóm đề xuất đầu tư lớp 4
và lớp 5 cho đồ án môn học và ứng dụng
phát triển vào trong phần thực hành thì
có thể là ứng dụng tra cứu hồ sơ liên
thông theo chuẩn.
Sẽ 7 cho phần thực hành 2 phần này nó sẽ
nhất quán với nhau và nó cùng xuất phát
từ một cái khảo sát thực tế có nguồn kiểm
chứng ở và nó dù tốt cho các cái đề tài
mà nhóm lựa chọn đó là.
Ở.
Thì đó là tất cả những cái thông tin mà
nhóm em thực hiện cho phần bài tập tuần
thứ 3 về xác định phạm vi thực hiện cho
đồ án thì em nhà cô có thể xem qua và cho
nhóm em xin thêm các cái góp ý để mà có
thể hoàn thiện bài tốt hơn ạ.
Rồi cảm ơn nhóm các em kéo lên trên đi
xem.
Cháu lớp 4 lớp 5 á.
Thì bây giờ về cái phạm.
Cái phạm vi lớp 4 trong kem dự kiến làm
về cái phạm vi thực hiện thì nhóm chọn có
tài liệu tham khảo,
chọn được cái công cơ quan.
Cơ quan để mình thực hiện xác định 2 lớp
4,
lớp 5 cũng ổn nhưng mà ở đây là câu hỏi
lại luôn á là các em định triển khai lại
hết tất cả các thành phần trong lớp 4,
lớp 5 hả?
Hay là các em sẽ tái sử dụng,
mình giả định cái ngữ cảnh ứng dụng hiện
trạng ứng dụng,
hiện trạng ứng dụng công nghệ thông tin ở
Bệnh viện Đại học Ví dụ.
Ví dụ giống như câu hỏi có cái.
Nền tảng phần cứng và các cái nền tảng
tài nguyên mạng ổn định rồi và mình sẽ
tái sử dụng lại nó. Lớp 4,
lớp 5 mình chỉ phát triển về cái hệ thống
phần mềm và các cái thành phần về quản
trị và bảo mật thôi chẳng hạn.
Nếu mình có dự kiến giả lập không hay là
mình sẽ đầu tư hết tất cả các thành phần
trong lớp 4, lớp 5 luôn.
Và chắc là nhóm em sẽ dự kiến giả là có
cô để mà nhóm em có thể lựa chọn ra các
cái phần ứng dụng công nghệ nó tiên tiến
và nó mới nhất để mà nhóm em đào sâu vào
nghiên cứu và trình bày cho cái bài nó có
chiều sâu hơn là việc mà dàn trải ra toàn
bộ lớp 4 lớp 5 thì nếu em nghĩ là nó sẽ.
Không có đào sâu được vào những cái công
nghệ mới hoặc là những cái cốt lõi như là
sử dụng cái nền tảng hybrid mà nhóm đã đề
cập, á.
Nên mình gia lập cái nào và đây các em
chọn luôn đi,
chọn để mình định hình cái thành phần mục
tiêu mình sẽ nghiên cứu nhiều hơn.
Dạ vậy cho cô cho phép chúng em được nó
cái này lại và sẽ bổ sung thêm vào cái
phần học tập này nha cô.
Rồi đúng rồi.
Vậy mình nói là mình nói mình chọn ha
không nên quá dàn trải quá nhiều rồi cái
Dạ.
thứ hai.
Về cái công nghệ mới á?
Cái em hình dung là khi trong ngành công
nghệ thông tin của mình mà khi mà mình
nói về công nghệ mới á.
Nó thông tin nó rất là rộng,
thực sự là thông tin ngành công nghệ
thông tin của mình rộng và có những khái
niệm là nó phát triển dần dần.
Và trong cái quá trình mà nó sơ khai thì
nó sẽ có khái niệm đó.
Trong năm sau nó sẽ có.
Thay đổi cái khái niệm khác.
Ví dụ,
giống như cái từ khóa mà em nghe rất là
nhiều về dữ liệu lớn,
chẳng hạn thì nó xuất hiện khá là lâu rồi.
Nhưng mà là đến thời điểm hiện tại,
người ta vẫn định nghĩa của nó vẫn thay
đổi theo từng năm.
Vào những cái thời điểm ban đầu thì lúc
mà mạng sợ mới ra đời thì người ta sẽ
định nghĩa dữ liệu quấn lớn với 3V sau đó
là tăng lên 5 V xong tới bây giờ là người
ta nghiên cứu rất là khá là nhiều Vy
nhưng.
Vì khá là nhiều,
vy là các đặc điểm của dữ liệu lớn á thì
nhưng mà nó hiểu tóm tắt ngắn gọn thì
người ta sẽ xác định khoảng 3 4 3 đến 5
cái đặc biệt quan trọng nhất của dữ liệu
lớn.
Nó phải có đạt được đặc điểm đó thì người
ta mới gọi đó là nhiều người lớn,
ví dụ như là dữ liệu tăng trưởng nhanh.
Tốc độ tăng đường nhanh,
đặc điểm đầu tiên vi của nó là phải tốc
độ ha tăng trưởng nhanh.
Vi thứ 2 của nó là đa dạng chẳng hạn,
có nghĩa là chứa rất là nhiều loại dữ
liệu khác nhau. Vì thứ 3 là.
Ở độ tin cậy không có cao là tại vì nó nó
là thu thập dữ liệu từ rất nhiều nguồn
nên nó không có thống nhất về giống như
dữ liệu trong ca sỹ dữ liệu rồi.
Nếu mà các em học môn cơ sử dữ liệu rồi
thì các em sẽ hiểu cơ sở dữ liệu thì chắc
là một cái.
Khu mẫu và các flu mình đặt ra và mình
bắt buộc cái dữ liệu khi nó được lưu trữ
nó phải theo đúng cái ru đó.
Thì dữ liệu thường lâm từ mình lấy từ các
nguồn ca sĩ dữ liệu thường nó sẽ đẹp hơn
là dữ liệu từ nguồn internet chẳng hạn.
Nhưng mà trong cái quá,
nếu cái việc giữ cơ sở dữ liệu mà người
ta thiết kế đẹp thì dữ liệu nó phải đẹp.
Còn không thì nó cũng sau một thời gian
sử dụng thì dữ liệu nó cũng phát sinh
nhiều lỗi chứ nó cũng không có.
Đẹp được ha,
đó là cái vấn đề chung mà cái nhà nghiên
cứu về dữ liệu bắt buộc phải làm phải
chấp nhận hoặc phải xử lý cái đó rồi.
Đó là cái đó là cô ví dụ để cho cái hình
dung là cái công nghệ thì nó sẽ thay đổi
hàng năm ha và cái công nghệ nó cứ thay
đổi liên tục.
Và cái chủ đề bài thực hành mà cô nói về
công nghệ mới là để cô cho các em có cơ
hội tìm.
Cùng hiểu về một công nghệ mới đang nổi
tại thời điểm hiện tại,
mỗi năm thực chất mỗi năm nó mỗi khác
thôi.
Thời điểm hiện tại và thường các cái dự
án mà phải áp dụng các công nghệ đó thì
nó có khả năng mới xung phân cao.
Cái này, cái này xuống chung rồi,
không có ai dừng ở một cái công nghệ,
chẳng hạn. Ví dụ,
ví dụ giống như mấy năm trước,
một số cái lĩnh vực hot như là bên.
Bên nền tảng blockchain lúc mấy năm,
mấy năm trước nó khá là hot cái mình sẽ
thấy đâu cũng nghe tới công nghệ
blockchain rất là nhiều.
Bây giờ nó vẫn gọi là công nghệ nền tảng
nhưng mà cái xu hướng nó bị.
Đi xuống chút xíu và cái suối hiện tại là
mình nghe rất là nhiều từ một cái công
nghệ mà mình nghe đâu mình cũng nghe là
trí tuệ nhân tạo.
Thực chất mấy cái công nghệ này nó cũng
tồn tại lâu rồi.
Nhưng mà vào cái thời điểm nó bùng nổ
hoặc là các cái giai đoạn nó đang được
ứng dụng nhiều và ngược.
Quan tâm thì nó sẽ nổi lên,
nhưng mà nó sẽ có danh sách một tốp các
cái công nghệ nền tảng hoặc có công nghệ
lỗi.
Đang nổi bật trong ngành công nghệ thông
tin và người ta muốn nghiên cứu phát
triển nó lâu dài như ví dụ như hiện tại
là trí tuệ nhân tạo này, điện tử này,
blockchain nè, điện toán biên.
Dữ liệu lớn mà cinen thì các em cái đây
nếu mà mình nghe cái từ công nghệ dữ liệu
lớn mà người ta đứng ở góc độ dữ liệu thì
người ta đang nói về cái việc phân tích
và khai thác dữ liệu.
Còn cái việc mà người ta nói công nghệ dữ
liệu.
Lớn mà đứng dưới góc độ mà xây dựng công
xây dựng để khai thác đường lớn,
xây dựng bộ đội ai á thì các em sẽ thấy
một số cái nền tảng mà chuyên xây dựng
khai thác dữ liệu lớn để xây dựng mô đồi
với ai á thì.
Cũng liệt kê vô cái công gọi là công nghệ
nhiều lớn nên cái tự công nghệ sử dụng
lớn mình hiểu góc độ khác nhau,
nó cũng sẽ khác nhau ha hiểu nó là ở dạng
dữ liệu thì nó sẽ là mình đang xác định
nó là loại dữ liệu mình để khai thác,
còn mình đã đứng góc độ công nghệ thì
mình đang nói tới.
Công nghệ kỹ thuật về masenal deep leanin
hoặc trên former để khai thác dữ liệu đó
và xây dựng mô hình ai chẳng hạn,
nói chung là nó sẽ khá là nhiều mà khi mà
các em chọn cái bài bài thực hành của
mình đó là đang làm quen với.
Cái một cái dự án phần mềm trong ngành
công nghiệp thông tin á.
Thì cô khuyến nghị các em nên đi sệt về
các danh sách,
các cái công nghệ nổi bật hiện tại hoặc
là không mình đi gần với Việt Nam mình
nhất hết em lên lên gọi là v v bộ khoa
học công nghệ á để tìm hiểu về các.
Cái nghị quyết quyết định về các công
nghệ lõi đang phát triển Việt Nam mình
đang muốn phát triển,
chẳng hạn thì đó là các công nghệ mới mà
gọi là mới và gần với mình nhất.
Tại có một số công nghệ mới ở nước ngoài,
nhưng mà Việt Nam là hiện tại nó hổng
phải là cái.
chủ động được cái không phải là ưu tiên
đầu tư thì thường nếu mà mình khai thác
cái công nghệ lớn thì nó khó sinh phân
chẳng hạn.
Ở đây là cho các em để các em vẽ làm quen
á,
nên nếu mà các em muốn search thì các em
search các công nghệ mới, còn cái việc.
Mà chia sẻ dữ liệu liên khoa á.
Nói thật,
nếu mà một cái hệ thống web mà xây dựng
một cách tổng thể thì cái việc chia sẻ dữ
liệu là một cái chức năng tối thiểu bắt
buộc phải thực hiện được.
Còn một cái hệ thống thì nó không chia sẻ
được,
có nghĩa là hệ thống nó nên đúng thiết kế
bắt đầu cơ sở dữ liệu nó tăng khai thác
không tốt hơn chứ nó cũng không phải là
một cái công nghệ gì mới lắm,
cái nó là cái chuẩn kỹ thuật để xây dựng
cái web chia sẻ dữ liệu thôi.
Nên đối với góp ý của nhóm Á thì cái bài
đồ án thì khá là phù hợp,
nhưng mà bài thực hành câu rồi cơ sở nhóm
đầu tiên các nhóm sau.
Các em cũng nhớ chú ý ha,
múa mình tự mình.
Lá hồi các em biết là mình xác định hoặc
là lá hồi các em báo cáo sau các em có
thể search trước hoặc các em có thể đưa
ra một số cái công nghệ nổi bật mà các em
sạch được và các em hỏi.
À trao đổi với cô coi cái nào nó phù hợp
với đề tài của mình cũng được thì cô có
thể góp ý tư vấn thêm để cho các em dễ
lựa chọn.
Em không sao.
Nhóm này nhóm của mình là cái phần đồ án
thì ổn,
nhưng mà cái phần mình thực hành á cái
việc mà chia sẻ dữ liệu liên khoa nó
không phải là mới em. Nó là cái ví dụ,
cái hệ thống nào mà hiện tại nó không
chia sẻ dữ liệu được giữa các chi nhánh.
Có nghĩa là ngay từ ban đầu,
cái hệ thống phần hệ thống thông tin quản
lý đó nó chưa đạt chuẩn á.
Nó, nó,
nó đang nó bị xây chấp quá nên nó chưa có
đặc chuẩn mà nó chưa chia sẻ dữ liệu được
chứ nếu mà cái dữ liệu đó là một cơ sở dữ
liệu dùng chung mà quản lý ổn thì thì cái
việc chia sẻ dữ liệu giữa các khoa OK
thôi có cái khó, một cái phần khó là chi.
Sẽ dữ liệu giữa các bệnh viện nếu mà nói
về trong bệnh viện thì có một cái bài
toán mà cô trước đây cô từng đọc và tới
giờ người ta vẫn chưa giải quyết được đó
là chia sẻ dữ liệu một cách an toàn và
tin cậy và đảm bảo quyền riêng tư giữa
các bệnh viện.
Tại vì thí dụ cơ sở dữ liệu thường thường,
nó sẽ trực thuộc quản lý bởi một cơ quan.
Và người ta sẽ chịu trách nhiệm về cái dữ
liệu đó nên cái việc chia sẻ dữ liệu ở
cái ở cơ quan đó sang cơ quan khác á thì
làm sao mình biết rằng cái dữ liệu mình
chia sẻ đi cho cơ quan kia nó được sử
dụng đúng mục đích và nó không bị làm rò
rỉ thông tin.
Mức quyền riêng tư của người dùng.
Nên hiện tại phần lớn các bệnh viện mà
nếu mà nó không cùng trong cùng một bên
quản lý á đó người ta rất là khó chia sẻ,
bây giờ với nhau thì có một số cái phương
án công nghệ thì bên blockchain là đang
làm về cái đó là người ta đang kỳ vọng là
làm sao mình.
Có thể mã hóa dữ liệu,
chia sẻ dữ liệu một cách an toàn là người
ta biết cái thông tin đó nhưng mà người
ta sẽ không thể giống như là em sẽ đọc
được thông tin xác minh.
Nhưng mà mình không bị các cái thông tin
nhạy cảm, nó sẽ được mã hóa và.
Và không cần phải không bị rò rỉ thông
tin và an toàn hơn.
Cái đó nói chung là còn đang nghiên cứu
cũng chưa triển khai được.
Thì nếu mà kem nói về công nghệ mới thì
kem có thể giữa các bệnh viện,
cái chọn cái đó thì mới gọi là áp dụng
công nghệ mới. Thì đó là gợi ý của cô.
Còn không,
một cái mà gần với cái ngành của các em
nhất mà cô hay gợi ý.
Là các em tìm hiểu về công nghệ.
Thí dụ bây giờ trí tuệ nhân tạo đang hot,
hệ ghi hoặc là dữ liệu, dữ liệu đang nổi.
Việc khai thác thông tin về dữ liệu,
khả năng nổi đó.
Ok, em có thể.
Giới hạn các phạm vi của mình về các công
nghệ trong lĩnh vực công nghệ,
trong cái lĩnh vực khác sử dụng lớn.
Ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo chẳng hạn.
Thì cái đó là đang gần với mình và đang
hot nhất luôn.
Nếu mà kem đã xây dựng nền tảng dữ liệu
thì làm sao để mình có thể khai thác một
cách tối ưu nhất cái dữ liệu của mình
đang có để có thể xây dựng các hệ thống
thông tin thông minh chẳng hạn?
Nó là cái gợi ý của con.
Đâu không em.
Dạ vâng ạ, nhóm em, dạ,
nhóm em xin phép ghi lại những cái ghi
Sẽ không.
chú này. Em cảm ơn cô.
Thì cái bên bệnh viện mà đặt hàng bây giờ
đang hết,
hiện tại đang hết đặt hàng luôn á.
Tại cô có tiếp xúc với bên đó,
bên đại học sức khỏe thì cô gợi ý cho các
em,
các em như người quyết định nhận là giống
mình ha.
Là đang ứng dụng công nghệ dữ liệu mới là
người ta muốn ứng dụng vào cái quy trình
khám chữa bệnh.
Hỗ trợ cho bác sĩ.
Dự đoán trận đoán bệnh.
Có nghĩa là khai thác cái khai thác dữ
liệu y khoa để hỗ trợ chẩn đoán bệnh như
độc và kết quả x quang,
đọc cảnh CT hoặc là làm bài toán
Passification,
dự đoán ví dụ cái ảnh X-quang của CT đó,
hoặc là kết quả xét nghiệm đó.
Thì mình suy ra là có bệnh hay không bệnh
hoặc là tự động làm cái bài toán sát bên
trên sân là thí dụ xuất hiện ảnh CT hoặc
ảnh X quang cái tự động dette vẽ khung
sát nâng tay xanh có nghĩa là mình sẽ vẽ
một cái khung detect đối tượng.
Và cái ví dụ trong bình thường của nếu mà
trong cảnh camera,
các em sẽ thấy cái này để dễ hơn chúng ta
là các em nghe có một số cái ứng dụng
camera,
các em thấy cái áp dụng bài toán
shoppination thì người ta sẽ thấy là có
một cái khung hình chữ nhật bao.
Sau cái đối tượng mình muốn detest,
ví dụ detest là coi có người đang xuất
hiện ở trong cái camera đó hay không,
có người xuất hiện thì sẽ có một cái
khung,
3 cái người đang di chuyển thì cái bài
toán kiểu đó người ta gọi là bài toán
shop anh ta sừng.
À còn nếu mà trong y khoa thì người ta
đang muốn đi tới cái gì,
ví dụ giống như ảnh CT là địa điểm test
cái khối u chẳng hạn.
Nhiều bài toán của mình là đi test khối u
trong ảnh CT thay vì sẽ hỗ trợ cho bác sĩ
đọc ảnh CT nhanh hơn chẳng hạn.
Hoặc là dựa trên cái lịch sử của hành án
hoặc là các cái khám truyền hình sức khỏe
mình dự báo ra các cái bệnh có khả năng
có xảy ra và hỗ trợ cho bác sĩ chẩn đoán
để tầm tiến hành tầm soát bệnh chuyên
khoa tốt hơn, chẳng hạn.
Thì cái đó là gửi của con.
Hoặc là người của Linh có kem.
A cô cô ơi,
cho em hỏi tí em cũng là nhóm 11 ấy thì
những cái những cái gợi ý của cô ấy thì ở
cái phần nghiên cứu thì tụi em có thể
nghiên cứu được,
nhưng mà đối với cái phần thực hành ấy
thì.
Thì để mà làm những cái thứ đó thì tụi em
đâu có dataset để làm được cô tại vì đợt
vừa rồi em.
Các em có đọc hướng dẫn,
các em đọc hướng dẫn bài thực hành chưa
và thực hành rồi mình đi thuyết minh thôi
mà các em cái cô này yêu cầu các em làm
đâu.
Ok, em xin lỗi.
Thế mình có chưa học chuyên ngành lấy gì
vô cái đó,
em muốn vô cái đó là cái ít nhất là các
em phải qua mua cơ sở dữ liệu,
qua môn lập trình hướng đối tượng.
Rồi đã học về data many,
học về trí tuệ nhân tạo.
Rồi lập trình web phản ứng dụng di động
rồi thì các em mới nhảy,
em mới vô được tới cái bài này,
mới vô được tới cái dự án đó triển khai
được các em.
Còn hiện tại của mình mới làm quen nên cô
cho các em viết thuyết minh thôi các em.
Có nghĩa là các em hiểu công nghệ đó là
gì,
mà hiểu cái bài toán đang được ứng dụng
đang được đánh giá cao hiện tại,
nếu công nghệ đó được áp dụng thì sẽ giải
quyết được cái bài toán thực tế nào rồi
mình và khi để giải quyết bài toán thực
tế đó thì mình cần phải hiểu các có các
cái bước.
Dạy có các bước triển khai nào và phải áp
dụng các kỹ thuật nào cái thuyết minh của
mình,
mình chỉ cần nắm những cái thông tin đó
là các em viết được thuyết minh rồi.
Nhưng cô chỉ cho để giống như là mình tìm
hiểu cái công nghệ nào sẽ được áp dụng và
nó sẽ được áp dụng như thế nào.
Các framework kỹ thuật nào cần tìm hiểu
để có thể triển khai cái bài toán dụng đó.
Chứ mình chưa có triển khai thì các em
cũng triển khai là các em phải học mấy
cái kỹ thuật đó.
Kem mới triển khai thành công được.
Đâu
Ờ dạ được được cô bắt đầu em từ đâu phải
implainment luôn.
Hiểu hình
Ừ ừ.
Đâu có đâu,
mình bà thực hành mà có mở sẵn ở đây,
mở cái sao sửa cho các nhóm khác đưa đi
mở hướng dẫn thực hành.
Sản phẩm của các bạn hướng dẫn thực hành.
Bạn Khánh mở đi em.
Mình học có trong một bộ 8 mũi ngắn tuổi
mà sao triển khai đó nổi?
Cái đó thường thường các bạn sinh viên
muốn triển khai thì các bạn làm ở dạng
khóa luận tốt nghiệp á.
Và các em học hết tất cả các môn chuyên
ngành rồi làm tới khóa luận tốt nghiệp,
mình dành 6 tháng đến 1 năm để mình triển
khai á thì sẽ xong cái dự án đó có thể
xong.
Ở dạng đồ cho thai.
Đất.
Thấy cái ồ,
cái điều project mà thực hành em.
Thực hành nữa phải thực hành nhiều phân
đồ thực hành.
Điều phương đơn hành.
Hai cái này nó gần tương đồng với nhau,
nhưng mà vẫn có một vài điểm khác nhau
nên cô để thành hai file hướng dẫn khác
nhau.
Nhưng mà kem có thể đọc song song được.
Đó.
Yêu cầu sản phẩm là gì em?
Của bạn nào nói.
Dạ dạ, cô cũng mới hỏi gì cô.
Đón bài thực hành yêu cầu sản phẩm và
thực hành là gì?
Mình đọc để hiểu rõ hơn hơn.
Bài thực hành.
Nhạc.
Yêu cầu sản phẩm là gì?
Đang bạn bằng khánh năng quét.
Dạ,
đó là các phần là chỉ là thuyết minh về
Mà thôi nữa.
các đề tài xây dựng một cái hệ thống phần
mềm cho doanh nghiệp như thế nào chỉ là
phần thuyết minh cho nó thôi.
Ừm.
Và cái phần thuyết trình thì mình sẽ cái
thuyết minh thì mình sẽ dí thành cái pha
thuyết minh ha,
sau đó rồi tới cái cào thuyết trình thì
các em cũng nằm tương tự như đồ án này em
có slide báo cáo và video báo cáo các
thành viên.
Là được.
Dạ vâng.
Rồi những nhóm 11 về sửa đi hả em?
Với lại mình định hình lại cái ý tưởng
hay là bài thực hành của mình?
Cho nó viết thuyết minh mà mình chưa có
triển khai thì các em sẽ được một cái này
các em làm mình ăn cho các em tập viết
thì mình đang viết trong cái trạng thái
này rất là đẹp luôn á.
Các em không lo lắng về cái nhân lực mình
có đủ nhân lực.
Và về cái công nghệ mới đó triển khai hay
không cũng không cần lo lắng là mình có
dữ liệu để mình làm hay không,
cũng không cần lo lắng về cái mức kinh
phí mình tự đề xuất được luôn mình đang
giả lập cái ngữ cảnh mình giả lập ra được.
Nhưng còn nếu mà đối với các bạn mà sinh
viên năm cuối làm khóa lần tốt nghiệp,
nếu mà các bạn làm cái đề tài đó đầu tiên
các bạn phải đi khảo sát và kiếm dữ liệu
có dữ liệu xong rồi bắt đầu mới tính tiếp
được ha còn cái này của mình là mình tại
vì các bạn phải triển khai.
Còn các em chưa triển khai và mình có giả
lập thì kem sẽ có tự do hơn và mình không
có phải bị ràng buộc về dữ liệu.
Rồi vậy ha,
nhóm 11 sữa xong rồi các em cập nhật cho
bài của mình,
ha nhóm nào báo cáo xong thì có thể ớt.
Dạ vâng ạ,
nhấn mời một cảm ơn cô và mọi người.
Rồi tiếp theo nhóm.
Nhóm 2
Nhưng hai bạn nào trình bày cái nào mà cô
đã hướng dẫn cho nhóm 11 rồi mấy nhóm xa
cô không nói lại nhiều ha,
cô chỉ nói rồi chú ý cho riêng của từng
nhóm thôi.
Nhật, cô có nghe rõ không ạ?
Rồi ông ấy rồi, em bắt đầu đi game.
cô là
Trình bày một trang phạm vi giống như các
bạn, tất cả nhiều những báo cáo,
nhưng không có trình bày lan man nha các
em, đúng theo hướng dẫn.
Trong cái phần Miting chat của cô yêu cầu
á.
Số 1 là quanh một cái project Scop one
một trang thôi,
nói về đồ án môn học và ý tưởng phát
triển hệ thống phân biệt ứng dụng.
Xong rồi tiếp theo là danh sách tài liệu
tham khảo của các em.
Rồi bắt đầu đi kia.
Dạ,
xin kịp bài về phạm vi của công ty cổ
phần thế giới động ở bước này,
nhóm em chưa đi sâu vào một phần mềm hay
một thiết bị cụ thể trước tiên nhóm em
xin.
Điện với là một doanh nghiệp như thế giới
di động thì nhóm nên tập trung vào đầu tư
các ngành,
các nền đầu tư vào những năng lực công
nghệ nào. Sau khi khảo sát,
nhóm chúng em gồm có 3 lớp 9, đó là.
Ở lớp 3 bảo mật và danh tính lớp 4 là nền
tảng ứng dụng và tích hợp lớp 5 là nền
tảng dữ liệu.
Về lịch sử phát triển thì đầu tiên,
xin nói sơ về thế giới đồng là thế giới
động được thành lập từ năm 2004.
Sau đó mở rộng dành sang nhiều lĩnh vực
khác. Hiện tại.
Thì những thương hiệu Pháp Phong thuộc mà
mình thường thấy như là thấy di động
ngành Điện Messon, Bách Hóa Xanh,
An Khang và nhiều các cái.
Các cửa hàng khác thì đều nằm trong hệ
sinh thái của thế di động.
Nhóm em chú ý ở đây là thế di động không
chỉ phát triển về mặt cửa hàng của họ
cũng như đầu tư phá nhiều vào công nghệ
để phục vụ hoạt động kinh doanh.
Ví dụ như trong tài liệu nhóm có tham
khảo đề cập đến hệ thống RP,
tức là hệ thống hợp lý,
nguồn lực doanh nghiệp,
hệ thống này hỗ trợ nhiều nghiệp vụ như
bán hàng, tồn kho, kế toán.
Ở mua hàng và bảo hành cho nên khi làm
bài toán này,
các em đã xác định được một điều là thế
giai đoạn đã có nền tảng công nghệ sĩ,
nhóm không đi theo hướng xây dựng lại từ
đầu.
Về hay là quy mô phạm vi hoạt động theo
tài liệu nhóm tổng hợp vào năm 2025 thì
có doanh thu khoảng 156.000 tỷ đồng.
Và mạng lưới hơn 6.
200 cửa hàng như vậy thì một doanh nghiệp
bán lẻ có quy mô rất lớn,
thế huy động không chỉ bán điện thoại mà
còn có các điện máy bạch hóa, dược phẩm,
mẹ và bé và một số hoạt động.
Ở thị trường nước ngoài.
Một điểm rất quan trọng liên quan trực
tiếp đến đề tài của nhóm là Thế Giới Đảo
hoạt động theo quy mô bán hàng đa kênh.
Hiểu đơn giản là khách hàng không chỉ là
mua trực tiếp tại cửa hàng.
Hết hàng có thể xem sản phẩm trên website
đặt trên ứng dụng thanh toán online và
nhận hàng tại nhà.
Hoặc đến cửa hàng lấy và làm được điều đó
thì phía sau có rất nhiều hệ thống kết
nối với nhau, ví dụ như là POS,
tức là hệ thống bán hàng tại cửa hàng.
ERP tức là hệ thống quản trị nguồn lực
doanh nghiệp CRM,
tức là hệ thống quản lý của khách hàng
rồi website app Forven và thanh toán.
Như vậy,
một giao dịch tưởng rất đơn giản ở phía
khách hàng nhưng phía sau có rất nhiều là.
Hệ thống khác nhau,
đó là lý do nhóm em lấy bài toán tích hợp
hệ thống và quản lý dữ liệu rất quan
trọng đối với lại thế giới động.
Về phần ba,
tôi có tổ chức và quy trình hoạt động về
cơ cấu tổ chức thì nhóm AL không đi sâu
vào toàn bộ doanh nghiệp.
Nhóm chỉ tập trung vào những bộ phận liên
quan trực tiếp đến đề tài,
ví dụ như công nghệ thông tin,
an toàn thông tin.
Vẫn hồng chuối mua hàng kho bẩn tài chính
kế toán và chăm sóc khách hàng.
Còn nếu nhìn vào quy trình nghiệp vụ nhóm
em,
mô hình hóa đơn giản như sau là doanh
nghiệp nhập hàng.
Sau đó,
quản lý sản phẩm tồn kho tiếp theo là bán
hàng rồi đến thanh toán giao hàng,
bảo hành hoặc đổi trả chăm sóc khách hàng
và cuối cùng là phân tích dữ liệu để phục
vụ quản lý. Điểm đáng chú ý là các.
Bước này không nằm trong hệ thống duy
nhất,
ví dụ bán hàng có thể liên quan đến POS,
tồn kho lại liên quan đến RP,
khách hàng liên quan đến CRM.
Giao hàng là liên quan đến logistics.
Ngoài ra,
Thế Di động còn phải kết nối với ngân
hàng, đơn vị thanh toán,
nhà cung cấp và các đối tác bên ngoài.
Cho nên từ phần khảo sát này, nhóm em.
Đi đến ngành định là thế giới động cần
một nền tảng được tốt để vừa kết nối hệ
thống, vừa quản lý dữ liệu,
đồng thời vẫn đảm bảo an toàn thông tin.
Phạm vi năng lực đầu tư là sau khi tạo
phát doanh nghiệp.
Nhóm mà em bắt đầu xác định phạm vi đầu
tư ở đây,
nhóm nào không nói là thế giới động phải
mua sản phẩm A hay sản phẩm B,
nhóm em đi theo hướng rộng hơn.
Đó là xác định năng lực hệ thống cần có.
Và nếu mà em chọn 3 lớp lớp đầu tiên là.
Bảo mật và danh tính đối với lớp này thì
nhóm em đặt ra một câu hỏi khá đơn giản
là ai đang vào hệ thống người đó thực
hiện những phần nào và nếu có vấn đề xảy
ra thì mình phát hiện bằng cách nào.
Ví dụ với ví dụ với MFA thì người dùng
không chỉ nhập mật khẩu mà có thể phải
xác nhập thêm bằng số điện thoại hoặc mã
xác thực.
Tiếp theo là PAM dùng để quản lý các tài
khoản đặc quyền như tài khoản Quảng Trị
còn EDV và XDR thì hỗ trợ phát triển
những dấu hiệu bất thường.
Trên hệ trên thiết bị và hệ thống.
Thì lớp 4 là nền tảng ứng dụng và tích
hợp.
Nếu nói đơn giản thì lớp này có nhiệm vụ
là giúp cho hệ thống nói chuyện được với
nhau. Ví dụ ở thế giới động có RP, CRM.
PoS, website App khoa vận hành thanh toán.
Nếu hệ thống nào cũng tự kết nối trực
tiếp với tất cả hệ thống còn lại thì phát
triển về sau càng rối và càng khó quản lý.
Cho nên nhóm đề xuất một nền tảng ứng
dụng chung, ví dụ như API.
Gateway có thể hiểu giống như là một cổng
giao tiếp chung các hệ hệ thống trao đổi
dữ liệu đi qua cổng này thay vì một bên
tự kết nối một kiểu. Tiếp theo là.
Messi tức là hàng hàng đợi thông điệp và
event stream, tức là luồng sự kiện. Ví dụ,
một khách hàng vừa mua một chiếc điện
thoại tại cửa hàng.
Ngay sau khi giao dịch hoàn thành thì hệ
thống có thể phát hiện một sự kiện.
Lớp 5 là nền tảng dữ liệu.
Đây cũng là phần nhóm men đánh giá khá
cao,
khá quan trọng trong đối với Thế Giới Di
Động.
Bởi vì dữ liệu của Thế Giới Động không
nằm một chỗ dữ liệu.
Có thể đến từ các POS, cửa hàng EDP, CRM,
vân vân.
Nếu mỗi hệ thống dữ liệu riêng theo một
cách khác nhau thì rất dễ.
Xảy ra tình trạng là dữ liệu không đồng
nhất,
ví dụ của một khách hàng như trên hệ
thống này ghi một thông tin hệ thống khác
ghi thông tin khác.
Hoặc cùng một sản phẩm,
những mã sản phẩm thông tin giữa các kho
và hệ thống bán hàng không giống nhau.
Cho nên nhóm chúng em đề xuất xây dựng
cũng có lớp 5 dùng chung,
trong đó là data boyhouse và lớphouse có
thể hiểu đơn giản là nơi tập trung dữ
liệu để phục vụ phân tích.
Ở tóm tắt phạm vi dự án là sau khi xác
định xong 3 lớp thì nhóm chúng em tổng
hợp lại thành một project,
tức là bạn tóm tắt.
Của phạm vi dự án trên một trang.
Tên tên dự án của nhóm em là đầu tư năng
lực nền tảng số tích hợp và bảo mật dữ
liệu cho hệ sinh thái của thế giới động.
Mục tiêu là mục tiêu chung là giúp cho hệ
thống thế giới động kết nối với nhau an
toàn hơn, dữ liệu được trao đổi ổn định.
Và doanh nghiệp quản lý được với a người
dùng, quyền truy cập dữ liệu tốt hơn.
Ở phạm vi cần làm và.
Bao gồm bảo mật tài khoản và quyền truy
cập,
bảo vệ ứng dụng và dữ liệu tích hợp API
giữa các hệ thống,
các nền tảng trao đổi sự kiện.
Lộ trình lộ trình lộ trình trong 36 tháng
thì về thời gian nhóm dự kiến triển khai
trong 36 tháng, chia thành 4 giai đoạn,
giai đoạn đầu từ 0 đến 6 tháng là chủ yếu
khảo sát tình trạng giai đoạn 2 từ 6 đến
18 tháng.
Là bắt đầu chỉnh khai các phần như khai ở
SIM,
SOC và PAM ở phía bảo mật giai đoạn 3 từ
18 đến 14 tháng là tiếp tục tăng cường
bảo mật.
Triển khai quản trị giữa dữ liệu và chất
lượng dữ liệu giai đoạn cuối từ 24 tháng
đến 36 tháng là mở rộng ra toàn doanh
nghiệp.
Ở cái D là mối quan hệ giữa 3 lớp.
Phần này nhóm em giải thích tại sao lại
chọn đúng 3 lớp này, lớp 3,
3 lớp này thực tế.
Liên kết với nhau phía trên ứng dụng
nghiệp vụ của thế huy động như là RP, CRM,
POS,
logistics và thanh toán lớp 4 là nền tảng.
Ứng dụng và tích hợp sẽ giúp các hệ thống
này trao đổi thông tin với nhau,
còn lớp 3 là bảo mật danh tính thì không
đứng riêng một chỗ mà phải bảo vệ xuyên
suốt từ người dùng quyền truy cập ứng
dụng API.
Ờ thích bị cho đến a dữ liệu.
Kết luận là sau khi khảo sát,
nhóm em nhận thấy là đã là một doanh
nghiệp có nền tảng công nghệ khá lớn,
cho nên hướng của nhóm không phải là xây
dựng lại cho thế giới giai đoạn từ đầu mà
là củng cố những nền tảng quan trọng.
Để hệ thống hiện tại hoạt động tốt hơn,
có thể mở rộng trong tương lai.
Ở 3 lớp năng lực tập trung là bảo vệ danh
tính,
ứng dụng và tích hợp và nền tảng dữ liệu.
Và phần trình bày của nhóm em đến đây.
Hết rồi cô.
Rồi các em.
Chưa sao, chưa nói gì hết mà cái.
Quay lại cái phần bên kia đi kem ở đây
sẵn cô nhắc lại luôn,
tại hai nhóm đầu thì cô cho kem chưa quen
thì cô để cho các em trình bày cô sửa.
Các nhóm sau các kem chú ý.
Là mình trình bày đúng vào cái nội dung
cần trao đổi để có thể làm thôi.
Các em còn về cái lịch sử phát triển công
ty thì các em có thể giới thiệu sơ để cô
và các bạn nắm thông tin được.
Sau đó mình vô trọng tâm chính tránh nói
quá dài và bên phần lịch sử và cái quy mô
phát triển của nó quá nhiều.
Thí dụ,
cái em muốn nói đó để các em xác định
ngược cảnh á thì các em nói vô về quy mô
và em sẽ nói về ngược cảnh giả lập,
thí dụ công ty đó cái nền tảng nào nó đã
lớp lịch nào đã phát triển tốt,
hoặc là các thành phần nào đó ổn rồi.
Và cái xuống định hướng định hướng phát
triển của công ty trong 10 năm tới là
người ta phát triển về cái phần lĩnh vực
gì, phát triển năng lực,
nhóm năng lực nào đó,
nên nếu mà em chọn phát triển các nhóm
năng lực này tương ứng với cái hướng định.
Phát triển tương lai của cái công ty đó
chẳng hạn để làm cơ sở kem miễn luận thì
mình có thể trình bày,
nhưng đừng có trình bày quá trình,
không nên trình bày mất quá nhiều thời
gian mà cái phần giới thiệu ngắn đó ha
thì cái đó nó phải trọng tâm.
Chủ yếu là để cho cô và các bạn nắm rõ
cái hiện trạng và cái mục tiêu phát triển
của công ty,
rồi các cái dự án của em nó có phát triển
dùng để cải tiến cái hiện trạng đó và đi
theo cái xu hướng phát triển của.
Không thì không chỉ cần nắm cái đó là
được ha.
Với lại làm quan trọng với cái đó với lại
cái ý tưởng phát triển phần mềm ứng dụng
công nghệ cho bài thực hành của mình.
Thì giống mình là không có nói rõ.
Nếu trên số tài liệu tham khảo của em dự
kiến là em có được các từ nguồn tài liệu
thông khảo nào rồi?
Các nhóm tiếp theo nhớ chuối.
Rồi bây giờ mình nói lại về các đồ án vô
học thì ba em chọn 3 lớp, nó cũng hợp lý.
3 nói chung 3 lớp nó cũng ổn nhưng mà các
em có giả lập là các thành phần nào nó sẽ
đã tồn tại và các em chỉ tập trung vào
một vài thành phần.
Các em làm hết.
Chỉ tập trung một vài thành phần thôi cô.
Là cái nào các em xác định xác định trong
cái phạm vi của mình.
Ở đây các em sắp xếp mình chưa?
Tụi em cũng có xét nghiệm sơ sơ rồi.
Thí dụ nhớ cái bảng.
Giống như trong cái bảng đó,
bây giờ mình chỉ cần xác định đến chéo
bảng nào mình không có rồi bạn nào xin đi
là có rồi thì mình sẽ đánh chéo mình sẽ
không nghiên cứu sâu về cái thành phần đó.
Nhớ cái bảng lớp văn bản xạ không?
Dạ.
Vừa cho cái bản ánh xã đó,
tôi xác định phạm vi luôn để miêu tả chân
khớp luôn, dễ hình dung hơn.
Bán xã hội ở trước,
nhóm hôm trước có sữa đó.
Dạ rồi ạ.
Dạ để nhóm em note lại,
nhóm em sửa lại khúc này nha cô.
Nhóm thường
Ừ
Rồi chính sách đồ để tham khảo,
khảo sát thì nay cô có thấy một luật sơ
cái ta để thông khảo của em rồi,
nói chung cũng có nguồn tài liệu ha.
Còn cái gì nhưng mà còn cái bài thực hành.
Dạ.
Kem định xây dựng cái phần mềm ứng dụng
công nghệ mới nào.
Và các công nghệ mới như là.
Chọn 1 thôi em bài tất hạnh của mình nó
nhỏ hơn,
Chọn 1.
kem nó y chang như cái bài đào án,
chọn 1 quy trình.
Trong một quy trình và em và một công
nghệ mới để mình triển khai thôi,
Cảm nhận quy trình.
cái em tại cái em mới làm quen,
đừng có nhào vô mấy cái dự án kiểu lớn
rồi các em nói cái phạm vi của em là em
sẽ áp dụng cho nhiều quy trình hay là
trên toàn thể cái đó. Rồi em ứng dụng.
Rất nhiều công nghệ là các em sẽ không có
đi sâu vào cái nào được đâu.
Các em đâu phải là nhóm nghiên cứu mạnh
dự án 5, 10 năm đâu.
Dự án 5 10 năm không có dự án 5 năm đâu,
thí dụ dự án từ 3 đến 5 năm triển khai á
thì phần mềm kiểu đó thì vẫn có thể vẫn
có.
Nhưng mà ở đây là một cái em mới làm quen
và mục tiêu để cô cho các em có cơ hội
hiểu về một công nghệ kỹ về các kỹ thuật
triển khai và công nghệ và khi mà ứng
dụng vô một bài toán cụ thể nó ra làm sao
thôi.
Nên ở đây các em chọn tốt nhất là một quy
trình và một công nghệ mới.
Dạ.
Nhóm em mình đang đang nói quy trình công
nghệ event streamerco.
Quy trình đó gì,
quy trình đó cho ai sử dụng?
Cái quy trình này cho hệ thống sử dụng
của con.
Để một giao dịch được thực hiện ở đâu nó
cũng có sự kiện bán về em.
Em nói gì? Nó là những diễn tả kỹ hơn cơ.
Khi một giao dịch được thực hiện ở trên
POS hoặc hệ thống phát hiện ra sự kiện
bán hàng của cô thì sự kiện này.
Được truyền thời gian thực đến hệ thống
tồn kho luôn. Cô như CRM,
chương trình khách hàng thân thiết.
Cái đó là cái công nghệ triển khai truyền
thông em, cái nhóm của mình,
các em cô biết là các em không phải
chuyên ngành về cái này nên khi các em
đọc công nghệ á,
các em nó chỉ là một kỹ thuật hệ thống
phần mềm thôi các em.
Dạ.
Kỹ thuật khác công nghệ,
công nghệ từ hệ thống người ta lạm dụng
khá là nhiều nên nhiều khi mình nghe rất
là nhầm. Khi mà cô nói công nghệ mới,
công nghệ mới ở đây thì cô đang muốn nói.
Cái góc độ là các công nghệ nổi bật hiện
tại á.
Thí dụ, em nghe từ công nghệ vô điều lớn,
công nghệ trí tuệ nhân tạo,
công nghệ điện toán lượng tử,
công nghệ điện toán biên.
Cái công nghệ trong đó nó có rất nhiều
tính nghiên cứu và rất là phải tìm hiểu
rất nhiều kỹ thuật triển khai á.
Thì cô đang nói về cái công nghệ đó.
Dạ.
Chứ nó không phải đơn thuần ở cái khu hợp
trình xây dựng hay là một cái IBI đang sử
dụng trong một cái hệ thống web.
Hiểu Hương.
Dạ dạ.
Ừ.
Cái này cho nhóm em note lại được xíu nữa,
nhóm em họp rồi báo cáo lại được không cô?
Ở các nhóm stock,
nhóm những trang nhấn sao tự sợ này có
mới dùng ví dụ cho nhóm 11 rồi ha.
Nếu mà các em không hình dung đúng không?
Các em lên coi danh sách công nghệ cốt
lõi đang mà Việt Nam mình dự kiến phát
triển nè,
nó có danh sách có nghị quyết luôn đó.
Nếu mà các em không nghĩ ổng tìm hiểu
quen.
Hoặc không là gõ tốt các công nghệ nổi
bật hiện tại trong cái lĩnh vực công nghệ
thông tin,
khoa học dữ liệu này hiện tại của mình.
Công nghệ đang nói công nghệ ở đây là
đang nói về công nghệ phạm vi lớn nha các
em. Và các em,
thí dụ các em vô em áp dụng công nghệ đó
vô một cái bài toán cụ thể thì mình mất
đầu đi tìm hiểu các kỹ thuật triển khai.
Thằng là cái hướng phát triển về hướng
phát triển.
Trong một bài toán cụ thể nó sẽ triển
khai như thế nào?
Dạ.
Em cảm ơn cô mà cô ơi, hình như.
Hình như cái bài này có nộp bài không cô?
Có chứ em cũng có tạo lại mà.
Hôm bữa trước hình như nhóm.
Thầy nhớ mình hỏi cô câu lại.
Những bài nào cô giao cô đều tạo một có
sang minh mà.
Nhóm em buổi trước.
Những nhóm em buổi trước.
Ờ không có nộp nộp kịp cái bữa khoa học
đó,
tôi thì cô có mở lại giúp nhóm em với
được không cô?
Nếu mà chưa nạp mà các em có tạo cái
fonder bài tập xác định phạm vi đề xuất
tin right của mình trong phần trong
fonder bài tập trên lớp luôn.
Dạ có.
Rồi cô sẽ coi trên đó,
mấy buổi xa bài tập sau nhớ Ngọc Linh cho
Dạ.
trung tâm kiểm tra nhé.
Giai đoạn.
Dạ là con có một cô ạ.
Nhóm tiếp theo có nhóm là xung phong luôn.
Dạ nhóm 10 ạ.
Rồi để những người xe đi em.
Các nhóm sao chuối vô trọng tâm nội dung.
Dạ, cô thấy màn hình trên xe chưa?
Rồi cô thấy rồi, em bắt đầu đi.
À dạ, em xin bắt đầu ạ,
giống như em lựa chọn ngân hàng cổ phần
thương mại Tiên Phong,
TB Bank là đối tượng nghiên cứu và giúp
em xin sơ luật qua về sự phát triển.
Và cũng như là mô phạm vi và mô hình hoạt
động của TPBank,
TPBan được thành lập vào năm 2008 và định
hướng phát triển theo mô hình ngân hàng
hiện đại và trong đó công nghiệp ngân
hàng số là một trong những trọng tâm.
À
Từ bên của các nghiệp vụ ngân hàng như
kinh doanh vận hành công nghệ thông tin,
quản lý rủi ro và các bộ phận hỗ trợ,
các hoạt động chính quy xoay quanh quy
trình tiếp nhận và quản lý khách hàng,
xác thực.
Cung cấp dịch vụ và quản lý giao dịch và
quản lý dữ liệu.
Do thời gian thuyết trình có giới hạn nên
cháu em xin đi vào lớp năng lực dự kiến
đầu tư luôn ạ.
Ở là do từ quá trình khảo sát,
nhóm lựa chọn Scility and Denity là năng
lực đầu tư trọng tâm.
Lý do là TPBank hoạt động trên nền tảng
ngân hàng số nên quản lý á một lượng tài
nguyên người dùng lớn dữ liệu khách hàng
và giao dịch trực tuyến.
Vấn đề nhóm đặt ra là làm sao để đảm bảo.
Ở ửm đúng người được.
Hụy được truy cập đúng và tận dụng đúng
người truy cập được đúng tài nguyên và
hạn chế các hành vi giả mạo,
truy cập trái phép và dưới đây là một số
rủi ro có thể là nguy cơ đến chính tài.
Khoảng gian lận giao dịch và một số rủi
ro khác ờ.
Vậy nhóm làm gì để tăng cường quản lý
danh tính và bảo mật theo?
Vì vậy,
nhóm đề xuất tăng cường quản lý danh tính
và bảo mật theo hướng nhiều lớp cụ thể.
Hướng thứ nhất là quản lý danh tính và
truy cập IM.
AAM ai dasty and access.
Lus management dùng để quản lý danh tính
và tài khoản người dùng thứ 2 là
authentication.
Tăng cường xác thực bằng MFA và các
phương thức xác thực sinh trắc học phù
hợp. Thứ ba là accessorol,
phân quyền dựa vào vai trò và nhu cầu
thực tế.
Ừ.
Ngoài ra thì còn có phân quyền theo vai
trò xác thực đa yếu tố phân quyền.
Cái này em bị lắp lắp cái.
Ở quản lý tài khoản và đặc quyền giám sát,
truy cập và phạm.
Và phát hiện bất thường.
Như là những trường hợp đăng nhập thất
bại nhiều lần từ nguồn truy cập từ môi
trường.
À.
Ví dụ,
khuôn mặt có dấu hiệu là giả mạo hoặc tài
khoản đăng nhập từ tiết mục thiết bị lạ,
hệ thống sẽ cho có thể là tăng mức xác
thực,
yêu cầu xác thực bổ sung hoặc là tạm thời
chặn giao dịch để kiểm tra.
Ngoài ra, đối tượng hưởng thụ của.
Nhóm tụi em hướng đến là 3 nhóm,
thứ nhất là nhóm khách hàng nhằm bảo vệ
tài khoản,
thông tin cá nhân và giao dịch ngân hàng
số.
Thứ 2 là nhân viên và các phòng ban giúp
quản lý.
Danh tính và phân quyền theo vai trò hạn
chế việc truy cập dữ liệu hoặc.
Hệ thống không cần thiết thứ 3 là các quy
trình hoạt động của ngân hàng,
đặc biệt là các quy trình đăng nhập,
xác thực khách hàng truy cập hệ thống và
hiện thực hiện giao dịch.
Về phần thời gian dự kiến.
O
Là nhóm phim.
À nhóm dự tính triển khai trong vòng 12
tháng cho toàn bộ chương trình Skill T
and Adentity ở.
Với các mục sẽ được triển khai trong các
giai đoạn và thực hiện song song.
Và phần tài liệu tham khảo.
À,
nhóm đã thu thập và tổng hợp các tài liệu
liên quan đến TPBank bao gồm website
chính thức của TPBank,
báo cáo thị trường thường đi với TPBank
và các tài liệu được công bố về hoạt động
công nghệ.
À
Ngân hàng số lớn và an toàn thông tin.
Các tài liệu này được giống liệt kê và
phần danh sách đọc xét ở tham khảo ở bên
dưới. Tóm lại,
và cuối cùng là sau khi khảo sát TP Ban
nhóm AM.
Làm năng lực năng lực đầu tư trọng tâm là
Skility và ADBT, mục tiêu là đúng người,
đúng quyền,
đúng tài nguyên và đúng thời điểm qua đó
là tăng cường bảo vệ khách hàng,
nhân viên và các quy trình của ngân hàng
được.
Trước các nguy cơ truy cập trái phép và
giả mạo nhóm em xin hết.
Nè là kem rớt số mấy ta?
Dạ, nhóm số 10 ạ.
Không phải các em theo lớp tăng lực số
mấy, lớp tăng lực số mấy.
Ai số 3
Áo lên trên cho cô cái chỗ mà lớp năng
lực.
Trong cái lớp tăng lực số 3 này.
Love show và.
Các em a.
Định làm hết tất cả các thành phần trong
lớp năng lực này luôn luôn hay là các em
sẽ đạt được cảnh đi giới hạn.
Và theo nhóm em thì đặt giới hạn thôi là
tại vì nếu tăng lần này nó cũng khá là
nhiều.
Cái game điều kiện là đặt giới hạn đầu tư
thành phần nào có rồi mình sẽ tái sử dụng
và cái nào mình sẽ đầu tư thêm.
Dạ đúng rồi.
Là cô đang hỏi,
là cái nào là các em dự kiến sẽ có sẵn và
À dạ.
mình chỉ tái sử dụng thôi và cái thành
phần nào các em sẽ đầu tư thêm.
Hiểu ý cô nói không?
Dạ em dạ em hiểu.
Nếu mình thảo luận chưa hay là đợi tuần
này thảo luận là dị sử là cái bài này sao
tiếp.
Dạ,
nhóm em chắc xin thời gian để thảo luận
rồi update bài này tiếp.
Rồi vậy cái còn về cái từ tham khảo thì
cô thấy giống mình cũng ổn rồi,
nhưng mà còn về cái phần mềm mà các em đã
ứng dụng công nghệ mới chị.
Ví dụ,
các em chọn lớp sẽ cứu rati thôi thì các
em phải tìm hiểu các công nghệ mới trong
cái lĩnh vực này.
Mời các em đầu tư phát triển hệ thống
phần mềm.
Bảo mật tốt hơn.
Kem đúng rồi, cô sẵn của trước nè.
Kết bạn thực hành với bạn đồng ý,
nó phải có liên kết với nhau nha.
Các em thấy giữa các nhóm 2 nhóm phía
trước là các bạn chọn nhiều lớp năng lực.
Nên thí dụ cái phạm vi các bạn có thể
chọn rộng hơn,
giống như là các bạn có lớp dữ liệu,
có lớp ứng dụng.
Thì các em có thể tìm hiểu về các công
nghệ mới trong lĩnh vực chuyên về dữ liệu
hay nói chung là dữ liệu với ứng dụng nó
cũng liên kết với nhau chứ nó cũng không
có tách biệt hoàn toàn ha thì sẽ có một
số công nghệ chuyên cho nhưng mà nó cũng
có một số công nghệ chuyên biệt riêng cho
cái.
Triển phát triển hệ thống phần mềm như là
một số là chuyên việc bên dữ liệu,
nhưng mà có một số cái thì nó là cận luôn
cả hai cái nền tảng đó công nghệ nó phải
cần khai thác con ca cái nền tảng đó nó
mới phát triển được.
Nhưng mà cái phẩm phòng virus của các bạn
chọn thì rộng hơn nên hồi nãy cô có đưa
ra một số ví dụ giống như những ví dụ các
em nào có lớp dữ liệu hoặc có lớp phần
mềm thì nó sẽ tập trung vào việc các cái
công nghệ mới bên nhánh dữ liệu như là
bên khoa học dữ liệu.
Chẳng hiện còn bên phần mềm thì như bên
như công nghệ phần mềm mới hay là cái trí
tuệ nhân tạo.
Còn thí dụ bên nhóm của mình là các em
hay sẽ kitoti thì các em cái bài vận hành
của em nó phải liên quan với nhau thì các
em sẽ tìm hiểu các công nghệ.
Mới về cái security này.
Các em có search chưa, các em dự kiến xe,
nó thử cho cô ký tưởng công nghệ mới và.
Dạ vâng ạ.
Dạ có.
Và
Cái em định xây dựng cái phần mềm gì cho
ai xài giải quyết được vấn đề gì ha?
Dạ,
thưa cô là nhóm em vừa tính vừa tính là
áp dụng công nghệ mới như là AI chống
dispex.
Aless detection là phát hiện khuôn mặt
giả tạo bằng khuôn mặt giả bằng AI.
Ngoài ra thì kết hợp với Zero Trust.
Thế
Hoặc là để khi mà ờm.
Dạo này thì ở các.
Các vấn đề lừa đảo liên quan đến không
gian số thì nó vẫn đang rất là hiện hành,
cái dùng AI để chống distic hoặc là line
this decision á,
khi mà hệ thống phát hiện giả AI để
chuyển khoản hoặc là như thế nào?
Ở phát hiện lỗi.
Chọn một cái thôi, em chọn một cái cho em.
Tại vì cái em phải hình dung nha,
À.
Ở thì em sẽ chọn.
cái kỳ vọng của cô chấm thi bài của các
em là các em phạm vi vừa phải và các em
hiểu rõ về cái đó nha chứ không phải là.
Cái việc đấy các em sạch ý tưởng chung
chung mà các em không nắm thông tin á các
em không trả lời được câu hỏi hoặc là các
em không nắm được cái cách nó được vận
hành cụ thể như thế nào thì nó sẽ không
đánh giá cao hay nha các em và nếu mà ở
cái phần thi của em làm quen á thì các em.
Cụ thể một cái thôi,
đừng tham nhiều quá em ví dụ mấy cái dự
án mà trừ khi cái dự án cô dự án lâu dài
và có sinh rất là sẽ thực hiện nhiều
nghiên cứu khác nhau cho cái dự án đó thì
cô mới biết theo kiểu tổng quát chứ mà
cái dự án.
Ngắn tầm 12 tháng á là nó sẽ vô một cái
cụ thể thôi chứ nó sẽ không có quá nhiều.
Nó sẽ không ôm đồm quá nhiều thứ đâu.
Thí dụ game mà biết phát thì làm đúng
biết phát thôi.
Nghiên cứu về công nghệ chống deffect để
xây dựng cái hệ thống ở đây của em với là
ngân hàng đúng không?
Xây để tăng cường tính bảo mật.
Dạ, vâng ạ.
Và an toàn cho các cái giao dịch thông
qua Face ID chẳng hạn.
Là cái giao dịch của em bình thường là nó
sẽ có cái thao tác bình thường.
Nhưng mà em nghiên cứu áp dụng công nghệ
mới và công nghệ deffect để khi mà nhận
diện khuôn mặt sẽ được test ra,
đưa ra để giúp cảnh báo.
Cảnh báo của nó chống giả mạo tốt hơn,
chẳng hạn an toàn hơn những hẹn.
Em đặt là cái ngữ cảnh đó,
thì em tìm hiểu đúng về các công nghệ
diffect hơn.
Để được.
Ừ nên, nhưng mà giới hạn một cái,
ví dụ cái em đó là các em đi vô công nghệ
đó và deepfast.
Xong rồi các em vô cái ứng dụng vô quy
trình gì rồi quy trình thực hiện giao
dịch tại ngân hàng.
Trong đó,
người sử dụng là ai sẽ là khách hàng sử
dụng. Và khi mà mình làm cái này,
mình đang đem lợi ích cho khách hàng và
nâng cao uy tín của ngân hàng chẳng hạn.
Thì em phải cụ thể luôn một cái vậy thôi,
mình tìm hiểu chi tiết nó là nó sẽ hay
hơn ha.
Dạ, vâng, em cám ơn cô ạ.
Giống em sẽ ghi một chút phần này và
Đúng
update phần tại sao ạ?
Ừ
Rồi chị cảm ơn nhóm.
Năm số 10 kem có khảo sát,
cập nhật khảo sát cơ bản rồi nên cô cập
nhật lên cái chú thích rồi ha nghe chú
rồi nhấn tiếp theo.
Nếu mà xung phong của em,
nhóm nào báo cáo xong thì có thể ớt.
Không có hơn, nếu mà xung phong, nhóm 5.
Không có nhóm xung phong thì cô sẽ gọi
theo thứ tự cho em rồi nhóm 5 lên em.
Dạ em chào cô, em đại diện nhóm 5,
cô có nghe em nói không cô?
Con nghe nói.
Dạ vậy em xin phép xem hình.
Được có thay được màn hình của em không?
Rồi cô thấy thôi.
Có cái và màn hình coi nó có bị mờ,
có bị mờ không cô?
Bợ bác bác vào đi em.
Không không không màng rõ rõ.
Dạ rồi, vậy em xin phép bắt đầu.
Giờ đầu tiên là phần project Scop quanh
quanh tay này thì em có trình bày trong
một trang này, em sẽ trình bày phần này.
Tin dự án là đầu tư nền tảng tích hợp
dịch vụ và nền tảng dữ liệu tập trung cho
hệ thống White Station,
đơn vị thụ hưởng là Wiseation hệ thống.
Superson gồm có 2 tính hệ sinh thái và
thể thao giải trí,
học tập và làm việc với hơn 34 chi nhánh
ở Hồ Chí Minh.
Lớp năng lực đầu tư,
tụi em chọn là lớp 4F và Interdation
Platform và lớp 5 data Platform.
Các thành phần trong 2 lớp này thì nhóm
em chọn là phần mềm quản trị và bảo mật.
Giả định phần cứng và hạ tầng mạng hiện
có đã đáp ứng đủ.
Dự án chỉ cơ kế thừa và tận dụng lại.
Thời gian triển khai là 12 tháng,
thiết kế đáp ứng nhu cầu vận hành và mở
rộng trong chu kỳ 5 năm.
Vấn đề cần giải quyết điểm nghẽn là
Withation đang vận hành song song nhiều
hệ thống độc lập.
Do là đang vận hành nhiều mảng khác nhau.
Cùng với các quy trình thủ công trên giấy
và zalo dữ liệu vận hành phân tán theo
từng chi nhánh.
Nên nên không thể tổng hợp kịp thời cho
quyết định kinh doanh.
Trong bối cảnh chuỗi mở rộng nhanh và vừa
bổ sung mảng dịch vụ mới.
Mô hình này làm tăng chi phí vận hành và
rủi ro sai sót.
Mục tiêu đầu tư cụ thể ở đây lớp 4 là xây
dựng tích hợp IPA Gateway Mid the Way kết
nối các hệ thống hiện có thành nền tảng
thống nhất.
Có hóa các nghiệp vụ đang thực hiện thủ
công, báo cáo, biên bản sự vụ,
đăng ký hội viên.
Về kỳ vọng KPI thì thời trang phản hồi
FPI trung bình nhỏ hơn 200 ml second,
tỷ lệ đồng bộ trạng thái đặt chỗ thành
công đạt 99%.
Thời gian tích hợp một chi nhánh mới hoặc
một loại hình dịch vụ mới giảm từ.
Vài tuần xuống còn 2 ngày.
Chi tiết về phần cái đầu tư chi tiết ở
lớp 5 thì xây dựng kho dữ liệu tập trung
vào quy trình ETL thu thập dữ liệu từ hệ
thống, từ nhiều hệ thống.
Thay thế báo cáo CE thủ công bằng
dashboard.
Tự động cho quản lý chi nhánh và khu vực.
Về phần mục tiêu KPI thì tự động hóa 100%
các báo cáo ngày, tuần,
tháng giảm bớt 95% thời gian tổng hợp.
Báo cáo thủ công bằng Excel,
báo cáo doanh thu và tỷ lệ sử dụng dịch
vụ toàn chuỗi được cập nhật với độ trễ
không quá 15 phút.
Đối tượng thụ hưởng thì có nhóm nhân viên
ca trực.
Quy trình liên quan tới nhóm này là thì
bên giao ca báo cáo bàn máy máy theo
khung giờ lập biên bản sư vụ.
Lợi ích kỳ vọng thì giảm theo tác,
giảm thao tác thủ công lặp lại dữ liệu
ghi nhận tự động thay vì đếm và ghi tay.
Đối với nhóm quản lý chi nhánh khu vực
thì quy trình liên quan là tổng hợp báo
cáo của ca tiếp nhận sơ vũ qua Zalo.
Lợi ích kỳ vọng thì là xem Det Voor tổng
hợp,
sư vũ có lưu uvad trên hệ thống thay vì
tin nhắn cá nhân.
Đối với nhóm ban điều hành chuỗi quy
trình liên quan là quyết định mở rộng,
bố trí nhân sự theo khung giờ.
Rất kỳ vọng là có dữ liệu tỷ lệ lấp đầy
doanh thu khung giờ và theo chi nhánh.
Với nhóm khách hàng thì quy trình liên
quan là đăng ký gói, đặt chỗ check-in,
lớp kỳ vọng là một tài khoản dùng chung
nhiều dịch vụ.
Giảm khâu điện thiếu giấy.
Phạm vi không bao gồm trong bài đồ án của
nhóm em thì.
Là đầu tư mới phần cứng với chủ thiết bị
đầu cuối, hạ tầng mạng chi nhánh,
gia đình là đã có sẵn và lớp năng lực còn
lại thì chỉ kế thừa không đầu tư mới
trong không bao giờ.
Dạ, tiếp theo là em xin phép chị.
Khoan khoan khoan chắc cũng còn lại cuối
cùng thì em đầu tư cái gì em?
Dạ nhóm dạ
Cái nào nó cũng có sẵn hết rồi.
Dạ lớp 4 và lớp 5 con.
Thế là lớp 4 lớp 5.
Dạ.
Và các thành phần ở dưới cái nào ăn có
vốn có 5 thành phần mà ở dưới em gia đình
em kéo dưới 5 cái,
nếu mình gia đình có hết rồi.
Thì các em đầu tư cái gì?
Đầu tư mới xong rồi mở ngoặc là gia đình
có sẵn,
Dạ không?
xong rồi ba lớp đang lực còn lại là lại
chỉ kế thừa cũng không đầu tư mới luôn.
Tức là
Thì cái nào có.
Tức là 3 lớp chiếu không còn là chưa,
nó muốn anh chỉ có đầu tư vào lớp 4.
À lớp 4, lớp 5, lớp 4 lớp 5.
Dạ lớp 4 5 thôi,
còn lớp 3 lớp kia thì là em sẽ kế thừa
lại.
Xong rồi,
gia đình là phần cứng và hạ tầng mạng có
Dạảng.
sẵn,
và em sẽ đầu tư phần mềm quản trị và bảo
mật của hai cái lớp 4, lớp 5 này.
Đúng không? Ok, cô hiểu rồi.
Dạ dạ đúng rồi con, dạ đúng rồi con.
Được.
Rồi tiếp đi, mình tiếp đi.
Dạ.
Tiếp theo là phần trình bày về phần chính
sách tài liệu tham khảo của khi làm bài
bài tập này.
Thì thông tin trong báo cáo được thu thập
từ 3 nhóm nguồn gồm tài liệu nội bộ cho
thành viên nhóm tiếp cận được.
Một thứ 2 là nguồn công khai chính chủ từ
doanh nghiệp và nguồn thứ 3 là dùng để
đối chiếu.
Đối với phần tài liệu nội bộ của doanh
nghiệp thì gồm có những tài liệu như là
dịch vụ giữ xe.
Nghiệp vụ vị trí phục vụ pizza,
một nghiệp vụ vị trí phục vụ cầu lông.
Ờ nghiệp vụ phục vụ sim nội quy phòng tập
quy trình hỗ trợ khách.
Tài liệu nghiệp vụ phục vụ nếp,
hướng dẫn chế biến món danh mục và danh
mục giá và hàng hóa.
Tài liệu nghiệp vụ của vị trí thu ngân
riêng, quy trình dẫn khách tham quan,
tư vấn gói tập,
tạo hội viên và lấy file ID danh mục.
Tôi nhìn một vật tư phòng tập,
tài liệu nghiệp vụ,
vị trí thu ngân nét bi da,
bảng giá hàng hóa,
công thức đánh giá món nội quy phòng,
quy trình kiểm tra phòng.
Tài liệu nghiệp vụ vị trí thu ngân nét
hub quy trình phòng hop danh mục hàng hóa.
Hàng miễn phí và hàng cho mượn thì những
cái thông tin này thì nó là những cái fan
nội bộ ở bên.
Western nên là cũng em cũng không có.
Như tài liệu này là có một số bạn đã có
một số trong nhóm em có trải nghiệm qua
thì có tiếp cận được những cái tài liệu
này thôi.
Tiếp theo là phần.
Rồi.
Còn nó hả, tiếp bị tiếp đi.
Dạ.
Tiếp theo là có đối với phần nguồn công
khai chính chủ từ doanh nghiệp là gồm có
trang chính thức từ We Station.
Cái trang dịch vụ không gian học tập và
làm việc.
Và thông tin các chi nhánh cổng tuyển
dụng của Wextation.
Và đối với nguồn thứ 3 là đối chiếu quy
mô và pháp lý thì cũng có mã số mã số
thuế Vietnamword,
các trang báo về việc làm 24 giờ.
Dạ, nếu em xin phép trình bày xong.
Phần đồ án là cái phần tài liệu ổn rồi,
nhưng mà bên phần thực hành là các em dự
kiến ít thông chưa thấy trên 7 tuổi của
em.
Thực hành đừng làm cái gì.
Cơ sở cho 3 nhóm rồi mà biết thực hành nó
nãy giờ bà ta trao đổi về cái gì không?
Dạ dạ, em biết file đó rồi con.
Mà do mới làm được tới đây chứ cũng chưa
có chốt luôn làm bài thực hành nữa.
Vậy là nhóm dây.
Dạ cái để em đem note lại rồi.
Ok vậy nhóm nhớ note lại ha tìm hiểu về
các công nghệ mới và cái mà gần gũi nhất
Dạ.
các em mà các em dễ làm á là các em phải
tìm một cái quy trình trong công ty của
mình và mình tìm hiểu về một công nghệ
mới.
Dạ.
Cái công nghệ mới nó thì tốt nhất là nó
phải cần theo 2 cái lớp năng lực mà các
em đã chọn cái công nghệ nào mà nó hay
được đầu tư trong 2 cái lớp năng lực này
nó.
Dạ dạ, em xin phép.
Công nghệ là cái công nghệ tiềm năng hiện
tại.
Rồi cái em chọn một công nghệ thì nếu mà
vô lớp đầu tư vô lớp năng lượng đó thì em
chọn vô một cái phần vi nhỏ hơn.
Cụ thể là cho nhóm người dùng nào trong
quy trình nào luôn.
Đấy,
cái lúc mà các em bắt đầu tìm hiểu á nó
mới cụ thể và nó nó sẽ có nhiều thông tin
nó phù hợp với mình luôn hơn.
Nó không hay bị chung chung,
nó sẽ không bị chung chung.
Dạ em, dạ,
em xin note lại rồi em sẽ làm việc với
Được không
nhóm lại. Dạ em cảm ơn cô.
Ok.
Ừ rồi, nhưng mình cũng ổn mà.
Nhóm tiếp theo.
Chào cô ơi, cho anh cháu 8 cô.
Có nhóm nào?
Nếu mấy.
Cho tôi là nhóm 8.
Rồi xem màn hình đi em.
Những 8.
Cập nhật cái.
Đăng ký đề tài đầy đủ hơn chưa em?
Giờ em cập nhật lên cái bài post cô.
Ở rồi trên máy cứ trên máy đi rồi cô kiếm.
Bây giờ tôi là.
Ủa,
cha cô không thấy ta là em cập nhật hay
là em.
Ở cái này là của bạn ca cập nhật trưởng
nhóm lên thì bạn đã cập nhật rồi.
Ai bạn nói edit lại.
Edit lại hơn.
Vốn kem có làm cái gì mới là kem play đi
em, tại vì cô thí dụ có cái nào cô đã làm,
cô đã nhập rồi cái cô hay like,
còn cái nào mà cô chưa thấy thông like
thì cô nghĩ là nó đã có rồi.
Là chưa có thì cô sẽ xử lý,
cô phải đọc vô nữa.
Rồi còn thấy nhóm 8 rồi được.
Bác làm đi.
Ở dạ cô là.
Còn nhiều nhóm lắm em.
Câu là nhóm em làm về cái Lotte Mart thì
lĩnh vực là sử dụng hệ thống sale
salepost,
nghĩa là sale check out thì nghĩa là
người dùng sẽ tự thanh toán thay vì.
Theo thông thường thì các cửa hàng bán lẻ
và các siêu thị thì sẽ ra quầy thu ngân
để thanh toán.
Mình trình bày và thật đồ án trước em.
Đồ ăn.
Trình bày đầu án và đầu tư chứ nó không
phải xây dựng hệ thống bán lẻ.
Thí dụ xây dựng cái hệ thống là vô cái
phần mềm cụ thể thì nó đang là bài thực
hành.
Các em trình bày cái phần bài nào quán
trước với tài liệu tham khảo rồi mình đến
tới cái thực hành thì nó sẽ dễ hơn.
Biết đồ ăn không?
em thì.
Biết đồ án nãy giờ bao nhiêu các nhóm báo
cáo và các em các bạn đăng ký các lớp
năng lực luôn?
Ở tiền nhóm em xây dựng lớp năng lực đó
làm dưới này thì là theo.
Ừ.
Mình chú ý các em,
các em đã báo cáo xong rồi,
các em đã báo cáo là nhóm sao rồi chứ
không phải là 1 2 nhóm đầu thì các em
phải nhớ trước biết mình cần phải trình
bày cái nào chứ có kinh nghiệm của các
nhóm trước.
Về cái phần.
Chi nhánh thì.
Tin nhắn thì của Lotte Mart thì có khoảng
10 18,
17 siêu thị và một cây hít Opice nằm ở
quận 7,
thì theo em muốn là khảo sát đó thì.
Thông cơ là quy trình thanh toán á thì là.
Ở khách hàng sẽ mua,
sẽ mua hàng gì sẽ bỏ hàng vào giỏ xong
rồi ra đến quầy thu ngân và thanh toán
tiền.
Thì khi đó thì các quầy thu ngân,
nếu mà số lượng khách.
Nhấn.
Kèm tầm xa yêu cầu rồi em.
Kem ngay từ lúc các em bắt đầu vô là cô
biết là các em làm sao yêu cầu luôn rồi
đó.
thôi cho.
Nãy giờ kem có nghe các nhóm khác báo cáo
không?
Dạ có.
Nếu mình.
Nếu mà mình có nhưng mà các em cần phải
biết coi các cái nếu có thì sao các em
tại sai vô đúng cái lỗi này.
Đầu tiên là mình phải trình bày về đồ án
môn học,
về cái ngữ cảnh và cái lớp năng lực mình
dự kiến mình triển khai và cái giả lập em
sẽ giả lập cái gì?
Sau đó là tài liệu thông khảo rồi bắt đầu
mới nói về vô bài thực hành là các em sẽ
dự kiến áp dụng cái xây dựng cái hệ thống
phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới nào cho
ai sử dụng.
Trong một quy trình cụ thể nào đó.
Sắp xếp nó bị lộn xộn, sắp xếp lại.
Rồi vậy, các em cô sẽ gọi nhóm sao hả?
Giống cát lên trước rồi đó quay lại giống
em sau đó nha.
Nhóm 5 lên hồi nãy nhóm nào văn ký ta
cũng mới thấy tin nhắn nhóm 6 đúng không?
Đến sáng lên đi.
Dạ cho cô và các bạn.
Để em xem màn hình.
Rồi cô thấy mấy hình em rồi bắt đầu.
Dạ dạ em chào cô và các bạn hôm nay nhóm
6 xin xác minh về phạm vi đề xuất của
nhóm 6 hiện tại ờ tụi em cũng là nhóm hồi
tuần trước có thuyết minh về.
Ở bối cảnh của công ty giao hàng nhanh
thì hôm nay em xin chọn về một cái lớp
năng lực là lớp thứ 2 về nền tảng vận
hành của Opplaform thì với cái lớp đầu tư
này thì tụi em có tham khảo những cái tài
liệu.
Tham khảo như là về trang chủ của gia hạn
nhanh về hệ thống của họ và về các hướng
dẫn đồ án môn học và các.
Công nghệ trên flow native comput
infaudation thì ở với những cái thông tin
như thế này thì tụi em có một cái ý tưởng
về.
Ở một cái lớp đầu tư đó là với một cái hạ
tầng trải dài xuyên suốt ở đất nước Việt
Nam như vậy thì ở đội công nghệ của họ đã
áp dụng.
Cái kỹ thuật về cái công nghệ gì để mà có
thể đảm bảo được rằng toàn bộ hạ tầng ở
trên toàn quốc đang hoạt động suôn sẻ và.
Ở
Thí dụ giống như là một một khu vực bị
mưa bão đi thì ở một cái khu vực đó đang
có khoảng 20 đô cục và 10 cái kho đang
hoạt động thì với một cái.
Vụ thiên tai thì làm sao đội IT có thể
nắm bắt được là ừ bưu cục kho bãi nào
đang bị ảnh hưởng và đang bị sự cố down
tham và đang bị chết thiết bị vì hư thiết
bị gì và camera có còn hoạt động được hay
không để?
Lưu trữ và tránh bị thất thoát hàng hóa
thì bài toán ở đây là tụi em sẽ sử dụng
những cái công cụ về thước đo như
Prometer Rafana hoặc là những bộ exacter.
Ờ để thu thập dữ liệu.
Ở đây tụi em xin phép là về cái phạm vi
giả lập và phạm vi được đầu tư thì với
phần cứng thì tụi em giả lập là đã có và
tập trung ở một nơi đặt tại data center
và với hạ tầng đường truyền mạng thì cũng
đã có sẵn rồi.
Ờm và cái hạng mục đầu tư chính ở đây có
nghĩa là cái lớp phần mềm và tụi em sẽ
gắn thêm một cái tác nhân AI vào cái lớp
năng lực này.
Ờm mọi người cứ hình dung là với một cái
quy mô lớn mà mình áp dụng một cái
monitoring of see belity mà nó.
Ừm thủ công thì khi đó mọi người.
Nhận những cái thông tin thông báo về
đường truyền mạng bị rớt nè bố cục không
còn hoạt động được và nó chỉ gửi bằng tin
nhắn thôi và rất là nhiều tin nhắn như
vậy gửi vào trong một cái ứng dụng như là.
Zalo hoặc là Tegram chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ
bị nhiễu.
Nó sẽ nhiễu rất là kinh khủng và con
người không thể nào đọc được những cái số
Phải hiểu rất là kinh khủng và.
liệu monitorin nó,
nó nhiều như vậy nên là tụi em sẽ có một
cái tác nhân AI.
Ừm.
Hay hay vận hành để gắn vào cái.
Cái monitorin và cái hệ thống lock để AI
có thể phân loại ra được và dự đoán được
là những cái đường truyền nào đang có sự
cố thật và những đường truyền nào đang.
Có.
Cảnh báo bất thường để từ đó có thể.
Xử lý được những cái những cái downtime
nó đang được ưu tiên ưu tiên hơn và ai
cũng sẽ có một cái vòng lặp quan sát và
suy luận hành động liên tục để từ đó có
những cái.
Kinh nghiệm và tự xuất ra một cái báo cáo
để cho đội IT vận hành có thể nắm được là
cái khu vực đó nên cần để trang bị đầu tư
thêm những cái thiết bị gì và có những
cái giải pháp?
Gì để tránh cho cái việc thiên tai,
lũ lụt đó,
ở không làm ảnh hưởng mất thất thoát hàng
hóa và bị.
Ảnh hưởng đến quy trình vận hành cũng như
là truy thu tiền bạc,
đó là cái ý tưởng của nhóm 6 ạ.
Rồi cô.
Cái phần bên thầy tham khảo với phần đồ
án thì cũng ổn rồi,
còn phần được thanh cái định triển khai
cái hệ thống phần mềm mới nè.
Và thực hành thì tụi em đang muốn triển
khai bằng một cái ALM local á cô.
Đó là với những cái dữ liệu về lock và
maritorine nó đã, đang có sẵn như vậy rồi,
nhưng mà chưa có một ai.
Có thể đọc vào và phân tích một cái dữ
liệu nó nhiều như vậy thì tụi em sẽ dùng
một hệ thống MM Local như là Olama hoặc
là một cái Open Short.
AI và triển khai một cái giao thức để có
thể tự truy vấn vào cái nguồn data đó và
có thể tự để tách ra được là dữ liệu nào
đang làm nhiễu và dữ liệu nào nên được
bóc tách ra để được.
Đội IT quan sát và chú ý.
Cô chưa hình dung lắm em.
Sử dụng mô hình eo em tette.
Và có nghĩa là giống như là với Jeminide
thì có API tốc cận của họ với Open AI.
Họ cũng có AI token của họ,
nhưng khi mà một hệ thống.
Của một công ty Interight mà gọi tới
những cái open,
những cái APE token đó thì nó sẽ có một
cái trả phí cố định và.
Cái phí đó thì nó nó sẽ rất là mắc nên là
tụi em sẽ tính là tự view một cái ai đó
giống như là jeminight,
nhưng mà nó nằm ở quy mô là local thôi.
A là tự tụi em tự giả lập một con server
và tự chạy.
Nếu dùng để giải quyết vấn đề gì?
Em ý là câu hỏi mình không có triển khai
Giải quyết đọc dữ liệu mất.
y trang.
Đọc dữ liệu và dữ liệu gì?
Em đọc hết là mọi loại luôn hả?
Dữ liệu về.
Dữ liệu về metric của các hệ thống đang
bị downtime này cô rồi dữ liệu về các
motorin của bu cục có đang online hay
không, hay là nó đang offline.
Rồi về camera thì cái bố cục đó nó có.
Đang hoạt động camera hay không hay là có
trộm đột nhập thì nó sẽ có dấu vết về gì
đó về cúp điện hay là bị mất thông tin
của camera thì.
Ngay lập tức,
AUM local cái AI local đó nó đang được
quan sát dữ liệu liên tục đó,
nó có thể nhận diện được và nó cảnh báo
đến cho đội ngũ IT.
Để người ta có thể biết được.
Nó cụ thể hơn cô.
Cái đó của các em rộng lắm đó, các em.
Trời giờ cái hệ thống nào làm được cái đó.
Các em nên chọn một cái thôi.
Ừm vậy thì tụi em.
Bây giờ cái em hình dung nè,
thí dụ bây giờ em nãy các em nói,
ví dụ là các em có camera và tới coi có
trọng hay không,
cái đó là bản thân cái đó là một bài toán
lớn rồi á nha các em.
Là xử lý dữ liệu video hoặc là dữ liệu
camera và thí dụ dữ liệu camera nhiều
nguồn, nó có cái phạm vi bài toán.
Bây giờ em là đưa một cái video vô là
detect coi có người xuất hiện hay không
rồi.
Nếu mà còn em depet là cái người đó có
chọn hay không nữa thì mình còn phải định
nghĩa hành động thế nào gọi là hành động
bất thường là khả nghi nó giống như chọn
em phải định nghĩa cái bài toán kiểu đó
nữa rồi xong rồi mình xử lý một video,
rồi xử lý dữ liệu camera.
Ra thì cái chất lượng nó sẽ giảm nha,
rồi nếu mà camera thì camera từ nhiều
nguồn phải xử lý như thế nào thì nội đặt
cô đặt 3 cái cảnh đó ra,
nó sẽ ra 3 cái phạm vi bài toán khác nhau
vô cùng một bài toán 3 cái mức độ triển
khai khác nhau rồi á.
Và nó là bài toán lớn đó nha.
Mình nói thôi là đủ là bài toán lớn rồi.
Dạ.
Thí dụ còn cái việc mà em,
thí dụ cái xử lý dữ liệu nào đang chậm á.
Còn nếu mà cái việc mà xử lý dữ liệu qua
cái dữ liệu đó nó đang có hay không thì
cái đó là nó.
Tôi thiên về IoT rồi là mình sẽ có cái
thiết bị IoT và mình sẽ nhận tín hiệu rồi
mình sẽ kiểm soát tín hiệu xử lý cái tín
hiệu dạng streaming từ các thiết bị IoT,
khi nào nó có hay không thì nó là một bài
toán khác nữa.
Còn với lại một cái nữa,
cái việc đi test đó, đi test cái đó,
nó là một cái bài toán phân lớp có thể áp
dụng nhiều công nghệ.
Còn cái thằng LLM chuyên xử lý dữ liệu
bên.
NLP thôi.
Dạ.
Nó cũng có xu hướng hiện tại người ta
đang nghiên cứu là triển khai em cho các
bài toán khác,
nhưng mà nó không có đa di năng như mình
nghĩ thôi các em.
Nó cũng còn đang được test.
Hồi nãy lúc mà mấy em miêu tả cô không có
hình dung lắm.
Dạ,
tụi em đang nhã lập ở đây là những dữ
liệu nó đang có sẵn rồi cô,
nhưng mà do là cái phạm vi dữ liệu của nó
rộng quá nên là một người IT họ không thể
nào xử lý được nên mới có một cái tác
Phạm vi nó rộng là sao?
nhân hay ai.
Ở em ví dụ giống như là ở.
Em khoan mã cơ của em hiện tại là ai?
Em actơ là ai là em chưa hiểu.
Là cái người mà các em muốn xây dựng hệ
thống cho người ta sử dụng á thì cái đó
người ta gọi là actơ.
Nếu phân tích cái hệ thống thông tin á
thì mình hay gọi nó là actơ á và actơ của
mình là ai ta là ai. Em định cho ai xài á?
Actor này đã sẽ là một cái đội vận hành.
Nó là đội đó là một cái đội ở trong công
ty và họ đang giám sát chất lượng của
toàn bộ kho và vô cùng của toàn quốc thì
họ muốn nắm được chính xác.
Chất lượng gì em, chất lượng gì?
Chất lượng vận hành hả cô,
chất lượng vận hành.
Chất lượng vận hành hay là chất lượng dữ
liệu.
Chất lượng vận hành có nghĩa là với những
cái bưu cục mà nó rải rác như vậy thì họ
không thể nào giám sát được là cái bưu
cục đó nó có đang hoạt động hay không?
Thì họ muốn nắm.
Vận hành của em thì em muốn ở cấp độ nào.
Là cái vận hành đó là thí dụ trong mũ cục,
nó có sẽ có nhiều cái dịch vụ khác nhau
đúng không?
Thì bây giờ em muốn kiểm soát cái chất
lượng vận hành của tất cả các dịch vụ hay
Dạ
là thông qua các feedback của người dùng
hay là thông qua cái?
À, kiểm soát cái quy trình hoạt động,
các cái các cái quy trình hoạt động,
các cái bưu cục đó các thông qua các tiểu
đường số.
Có thể là tụi em sẽ thu hẹp về phạm vi
hoạt động của internet thôi,
có nghĩa là nếu như một cục đâu mất
internet thì nó cũng ảnh hưởng tới cái
chất lượng vận hành của khu cục đó.
Nên là muốn giám sát xem là cái bưu cục
đó,
tình trạng internet của toàn bộ bưu cục
trên toàn quốc nó có đang online không
thì nếu nó có offline bất thường thì sẽ
có cảnh báo và xử lý.
Có internet này không thì nó đâu phải gọi
là detate em.
Kem phải hình dung ví dụ detect là sao có
nghĩa là cái giao dịch nó vẫn đó là tất
cả các giao dịch hoặc các hoạt động nào
đó đang xảy ra.
Và có cái hoạt động bất thường mình muốn
detect.
Thí dụ giống như trong tất cả các giao
dịch có giao dịch nào gian lận thì mình
sẽ điều test được cái giao dịch gian lận
để cảnh báo sớm.
Còn thí dụ,
còn nhưng mà bản chất của nó là một loại,
một cái sampon, một cái opset,
còn thí dụ cái việc có internet hay không,
có internet á.
Không có phải là internet hay không,
internet mình lắp đặt thiết bị IoT,
cảm biến.
Mình nó nó nó nhận tín hiệu là giống như
kiểu hệ thống quản lý là mình thấy được
liền á em.
Dạ em hiểu cái phần đó,
nhưng mà do là tụi em có tham khảo một
Ừ
vài tài liệu của giao hàng nhanh rồi á
thì tụi em có thấy những cái nguồn về
truy thu và về thất thoát tài sản á cô.
Nó sẽ có vài cái giống như là.
Ờ internet thì khi mà mất á thì nó sẽ
liên quan tới việc là camera cũng không
coi được ở từ xa này rồi internet thì nó
cũng sẽ làm những cái luân chuyển hàng
hóa của họ bị dừng lại thì có những cái
phần về gian lận thất thoát hàng hóa mà
họ.
Cái con người ở dưới của cục đó,
họ chủ động họ tắt internet,
nghĩa là mỗi thí dụ một ngày mà họ tắt
chủ động tắt internet tới 4 5 lần lận thì
đó không phải một hành vi bình thường của
một cái hệ thống internet mà một ngày nó
phải bị tắt 4 5 lần.
Lần được thì theo em này nó sẽ.
Giúp mình nhận diện và nó cảnh báo là cái
ông đó,
tại sao một ngày tắt internet tới 4 5 lần?
Cái nào không hay những gì khen cái em,
cái đó là các em chuyển từ cái bài toán
Nó cũng đồng ý đồ của tôi như vậy.
phát hiện sang bài toán ngoài giải thích
luôn rồi cái bài toán giải thích nó là
cái khác em.
Còn cái bài toán giải thích nó khó,
nó không có triển khai dễ đâu.
Thí dụ mình chỉ phát hiện nó có gian lận
thôi,
còn tại sao người ta gian lận thì cái đó
mang yếu tố con người rồi cái em thiếu
minh nó là qua một cái lĩnh vực khác rồi.
Yeah.
Nếu mà các em muốn làm như vậy,
họ là các cái hoạt động bất thường ở một
cái chi nhánh.
Thì các em phải giới hạn các phạm vi đối
tượng của em, dữ liệu của em lại,
ví dụ ở các vô cục sẽ có cái hoạt động
chính nào?
Mà thí dụ em giới hạn trong các phạm vi
làm quản lý giao hàng,
thi để mình phát hiện các trường hợp giao
hàng bất thường để mình đưa ra cảnh báo
sớm, chẳng hạn.
Là cái nó nó nó nhận được thực thi nó
đừng dẫn được giao dịch,
Nhạc.
nhưng mà nó không hơi bất thường,
nó giống như giao dịch ngân hàng vậy đó
là nó cũng có các cái yêu cầu,
nhưng mà nếu nó lại yêu cầu bất thường
thì mình sẽ chặn nó lại.
Còn nếu mà là cái ví dụ trong kho bãi,
quản lý kho bãi và để nó là quy trình
giao hàng có vấn đề bất thường thì sẽ đưa
ra cảnh báo thông qua việc phân tích dữ
liệu.
Nó giống như cái vụ bên.
À.
Bên động viên của anh,
tốt nghiệp trung học phổ thông chuyên của
anh nghe cái kỳ thi đó.
Kỳ thi tốt nghiệp trung học phổ thông thì
thông qua cái phân tích dữ liệu,
người ta phát hiện ra các cái thông tin
bất thường.
Thì suy,
nhưng mà nó chỉ là thông tin bất thường
và mình chỉ đưa ra cảnh báo,
có đưa ra cảnh báo là có xu hướng giống
như là dữ liệu allio một cách bất thường
hoặc là tăng bất thường hoặc là giảm bất
thường.
Nếu mà mình chỉ dừng ở đó thì người ta
gọi là phân tích dữ liệu thôi các em ha,
còn nếu mà thí dụ em dừng ở đó,
các em suy ra là nếu mà có cái dữ liệu
bất thường thì đây ra giao dịch bất
thường hoặc là các dữ liệu bất thường như
vậy là suy ra.
Đây là cái hoạt động thi cử đang có dấu
hiệu gian lận.
Thì mình,
nếu mà kem đặt cái bài toán kiểu đó thì
mình có thể gọi là kết hợp với tích hợp
giữa cái ứng dụng PI để mình đưa ra cảnh
báo cho nhà phân tích dữ liệu hoặc là cho
cái người quản lý admin trong quản lý cái
lastbo đó để người.
Cái cảnh báo đó,
nó có phải bất thường thực sự và lý do là
gì thì phải do chuyên gia xử lý thôi.
Sau này có một số hệ thống thì người ta
cũng đang nghiên cứu là hệ thống giải
thích lý do nhưng mà cái đó thì cũng đang
mới manh gia ban đầu thôi chứ giải thích
phân tích lý do nó có nhiều lý do lắm.
Chưa có cái bộ dữ liệu để xử lý lớn để có
thể làm được cái bài toán đó,
cái người ta đang cố gắng giải thích cái
lý do thôi.
Nếu mà những mình làm thì các em có thể
giới hạn cái phạm vi kiểu đó có nghĩa là
các cái lịch sử,
các hoạt động giao dịch và các em định
nghĩa hoạt động các em muốn detate.
Bạn chọn một cái hoạt động thôi chứ mình
đừng có cho cả cái bưu cục có rất nhiều
hoạt động thì nó có rất nhiều hoạt động,
mỗi hoạt động nó sẽ có các dữ liệu số đi
kèm với các hoạt động đó thì em lại phải
ra một cái bài toán phân tích.
Đi tìm hiểu cái dữ liệu đó đi phân tích,
tìm hiểu các kỹ thuật để xử lý cái loại
dữ liệu đó rồi để mình đi test ra vấn đề
nữa thì nó sẽ khó.
Nó sẽ nhiều á và nó sẽ mình tìm hiểu
nhiều hết, không hết nổi.
Và phải chú ý là LOS.
Nó không phải là cái thằng dạng năng đâu,
cái em nó chỉ là được.
Thí dụ giống như thời Deep Linin á,
thời mà Cinanin máy đây trước đây,
lúc mà lúc đầu á là kiểu phân có thống kê,
sau đó cái mà Cinanin ra đời,
cái mọi người đều cái việc mà cinanin mà
cinanin. Sau đó mà cinanin là tới.
Clip Lenin thì cái dự án nào cũng đòi làm
deep lên Nin Deepanin nhưng mà ai làm đội
thì sẽ biết Deepanin. Lúc nào cũng tốt,
sao sao Deep Linin bây giờ các tới các
cái mô hình transformer thì nó có 2 nhánh,
một vô các timcery hay một cái vô hay
hướng nhánh.
Đều nghĩ là đương nhiên là nó tốt nhưng
mà nó không có tốt cho tất cả mọi vấn đề.
Nên trong cái giai đoạn thí dụ các em nào
thuyết minh đề tài á các em chưa thực
nghiệm,
chưa chạy ra được thì ở đây sản cô nói
luôn cái kinh nghiệm với thuyết minh mà.
Cho mấy cái dự án kiểu phần mềm gọi là áp
dụng công nghệ mới.
Chưa trả, chưa triển khai,
chưa ai nói đều trước được điều gì nên
thường trong cái thuyết minh đó là mình
gọi là liệt kê các công nghệ hoặc kỹ
thuật tiềm năng dự kiến sẽ triển khai dự
kiến thôi nha.
Chứ mình không có khẳng định tại chưa
chạy chưa có kết quả mà.
Chả rồi,
có khi mình đổi hướng đi qua tắt công
nghệ nữa nên thường thường số cái dự án
thí dụ bên nước ngoài hoặc nó sẽ có cái
phần nó riêng,
còn của Việt Nam mà các chủ nhiệm chủ
nhiệm đề tài mà có kinh nghiệm thì thật
sự dưới một cái mục.
Là dự kiến các công nghệ thay thế tiềm
năng thay thế lúc mình biết á là mình
nghĩ công nghệ này nó tiềm năng.
Nhưng mà giả sử cái lúc mình thực nghiệm
mình phát hiện nó chạy không ổn thì mình
cũng có một cái câu hò là mình đi kiếm
một số cái công nghệ thay thế để mình có
đổi công nghệ,
mình cũng không bị gọi là vi phạm hợp
đồng.
Em hình dung không,
nên ở đây nhóm cô thấy mình nghe cứ eo em,
Dạ.
em không phải cái gì cũng eo em nha các
em.
Nếu mà dữ liệu theo dạng NLP thì sử dụng
mail của em,
transformer và theo nhánh IOM.
Nhưng mà nếu mà đó là đó là nó.
Liệu temsury thì nó là đi theo trang.
Đó là 2 nhánh khác nhau á.
Dạ, anh cảm ơn cô.
Rồi cái đó là cái gợi ý ha.
Thí dụ em muốn detect cái vấn đề bất
thường thì chọn một vấn đề thôi,
đừng có chơi nguyên mua cục như cái
nguyên mua cục có nhiều hoạt động lắm.
Làm sao để test hết tất cả các hoạt động
bất thường trên đó được.
Mà nếu mà mình gom chung thì nó nó nó
rộng lắm trong cái thôi.
Để mình tìm hiểu sao.
Còn cái bài toán đi test thì bản thân nó
chỉ là bài toán phân lớp thôi,
còn thí dụ em muốn giải thích thì em kết
hợp giữa bài toán,
phân lớp và các bài toán diễn giải chẳng
hạn.
Có một số bài toán đang đi theo hướng đó.
Dạ, cảm ơn anh.
Rồi nhóm vậy,
nhóm có hiệu chỉnh thì các em chỉnh lại
cái bài rồi mình cập nhật lên right của
mình á.
Rồi nhóm tiếp theo,
em có nhóm nào muốn đăng ký em?
Không có với cô thiếu tự ha nhóm 1.
Nếu 1 đầu kem.
Nhưng mà quay đi học không?
Những mẫu bắn cả nhóm.
Nhóm 3 có ai không em? Nhóm 3?
Nhưng mà cá này game.
Dạ,
cô đợi em để em bảo khách để em trở lại.
Ừ, những bài đúng không,
những bài đúng không?
Cô nói em coi.
Thì anh.
Các em cập nhật cái thông tin đề tài của
mình chưa?
Thông tin chi tiết về đề tài của mình.
Rồi còn 2 nhóm rồi.
Dạ rồi.
Nhóm 4 chuẩn bị hả anh?
Vô trọng tâm nha các em một trang.
Một trang phạm vi đồ án rồi danh sách từ
tham khảo,
xong rồi nói ý tưởng và thực hành của
mình.
Nhóm muốn có bạn nào đi học không?
Nhóm muốn chú chuẩn bị nha các em,
nhóm muốn có mở mic báo của biết.
Và có quốc gia.
Ừ, sao những bà tao nhóm 4.
Rồi cô thấy màn hình đồ đạc.
À, nhóm 4 nhóm 4 nhóm 3 đã có chút xíu,
có điện thoại.
Rồi những bài bắt đầu để kêu.
Dạ, alo, cô nghe anh nói không ạ?
Ở có nghĩa rồi, mình bắt đầu đi.
Dạ, trước hết em xin chào cô và các bạn.
Nhóm em là nhóm 3 sẽ làm về công ty FE về
mảng cho vay tín dụng và trả góp.
Về mảng cho vay tín dụng và trả góp đơn
vị FM Credit là công ty tài chính.
Rất nhiều hữu hạn Ngân hàng Việt Nam
Thịnh Vượng.
Và sau đây, nhóm em sẽ đầu tư,
nhóm em đầu tư về cả 5 lĩnh vực là không.
Công việc thì Connectivity, Ople Stority,
Identity app Interation,
platform and data và platform, tuy nhiên.
Về mã phân thì nhóm em sẽ không đi chuyên
sâu cả,
không đi chuyên sâu cả 5 phần và bên em
sẽ đi chuyên sâu về phần mềm quản trị và
bảo mật.
À trước hết thì em xin giới thiệu về tổng
quan về doanh nghiệp thì FE Credit là
thương hiệu trong lĩnh vực tài chính.
Về Việt Nam.
Giới thiệu sơ em hồi nãy cô đã hướng dẫn
nhóm trên rồi đánh thẳng vô cái phạm vi
Dạ.
của em dự kiến làm của công ty này thêm.
Công ty nào nó lạ quá mà nhắm làm nó cái
lĩnh vực ứng dụng nó lạ và các em cần
trình bày nó để các em dẫn.
Rồi cái câu chuyện của mình thì mình mới
trình bày,
còn nếu mà nó quen thuộc rồi thì các em
có thể đi thẳng trong phạm vi.
Dạ dạ.
À,
vậy em xin đi sâu vào phần sản phẩm đầu
ra của nhóm em,
nhóm em về công ty Connectivity thì cơ sở
trong cơ sở để bên nhóm em lựa chọn.
Này là về FE cần xử lý giao dịch lớn và
kết nối ổn định nên chúng em sẽ chọn đầu
tư vào communitage là lý do tại sao mà em
lại đi cả 5 nhóm.
Thì nhóm nào quan trọng thì một trong đó
là Kurity Connectingity về phần mềm quản
trị và bảo mật để hệ thống có thể scale.
Có thể scale nhanh hơn đối tượng thụ
hưởng của bên em,
đa phần là sẽ là đội ngũ IT đi đối tác
boss và quy trình giải ngân.
Thì dự.
Dự kiến.
Em Dương Lan cho anh nhỉ.
À
Dự kiến của bên em sẽ vào khoảng 12 đến
15 tháng.
Thì.
Tiếp theo là về cái về ốp lastform.
Oplitform thì bên em cũng đầu tư vào phần
mềm quản trị và bảo mật,
thì phần phần mềm giám sát sẽ có giúp.
Giúp có thể giám sát hệ thống thời gian
thực.
Về quản trị thì quy trình quản trị sự cố
chuẩn theo ATSM,
AT IELTS và cam kết được SLA.
Trong kết nghiệp SLA.
Về bảo mật thì sẽ giám sát an ninh vận
hành, lưu trữ lốc và quyền truy cập.
Đối tượng hô hổn của bên em sẽ là đội ngũ
vận hành panetty thẩm định kinh doanh và
an toàn thông tin về mỗi mục đầu tư thì
sẽ có thời gian dự kiến về phần này thì
sẽ là dự kiến sẽ là khoảng.
24 tháng là khoảng thời gian rút gọn.
A về Security và Adentify,
Security và Adentify thì lớp năng lực chủ
yếu dùng để phụ trách bảo vệ hệ thống và
quy trình danh tính.
Kiểm soát quyền truy cập nên là bên em sẽ
tăng cường xác minh khách hàng,
quản lý truy cập và bảo vệ dữ liệu thông
qua AM.
CIM APM sinh trắc học và mã hóa giảm giám
sát bất thường.
Về đối tượng thụ hưởng thì bên em sẽ tập
trung vào là khách hàng đối tác,
nhân viên đối tác nội bộ và các bộ phận
liên quan đến thẩm định công nghệ.
Dự kiến là sẽ hoàn thành hoặc trong
khoảng 9 đến 12 tháng.
Tiếp theo là về app integration flatform.
Về app Internet Form thì cơ sở để bên em
đầu tư là để tích hợp sự ổn định giữa các
hệ thống của nội bộ và hệ thống của đối
tác.
Ta sẽ được tập trung vào đầu tư software
góp Vơ Cecurity để chuyển hóa và tăng khả
năng mở rộng để bảo mật.
Thì đối tượng Hồ Hưởng tập trung vào hệ
thống nghiệp vụ đội ngũ IT an toàn thông
tin hoặc là đối tác Boss và.
Mục tiêu là để khách hàng có thể sử dụng
tốt hơn thì dự kiến của bên em sẽ là 12
tháng.
Là sẽ hoàn thành được phần app
Entertational English for tiếp theo là về
phần data platform.
Data latform thì bên em sẽ đầu tư vào
phần mềm,
thì sẽ nâng cấp hệ thống cho vay,
xây dựng data tập trung.
A,
công nghệ thì bên em sẽ chú trọng vào
database, data Bayer, data World House,
data Lay, API, Cloud, AI, ML.
Dự kiến của cả Blackform thì phần mềm sẽ
chiếm khoảng 6.
Thời gian đầu 6 tháng đầu.
Quản trị thì bên em sẽ chú trọng đầu tư
về việc chuẩn hóa dữ liệu,
quy trình và phân quyền.
Công nghệ tập trung chủ yếu là data,
gover.
Data catalog, BI, Word,
Monitoring thì sẽ khoảng.
Tháng thứ 4 tới tháng thứ 9 về đầu tư bảo
mật thì bên em sẽ tăng về cái phần.
Bảo vệ dư luận khách hàng và các khoản
vay như là công nghệ AMMFA,
Encrypt Fanwell.
Tiếp thị FCCIM make up đi a xuyên suốt 12
tháng.
Tài liệu khi mà nhóm em tìm hiểu về công
ty cũng như là những thông tin thì bên em
cũng có tổng hợp lại một số nguồn tài
liệu, nguồn báo.
Ví dụ như là.
Báo thuận niên hay là những thông tin
chính thức từ trang của FE,
những nguồn báo chính thống và những dữ
kiện giả lập về hướng dẫn quản lý danh
tính, kiến trúc.
Để có thể đưa lên được một nhu cầu cần
thiết,
có thể đáp ứng được cho doanh nghiệp và
phục vụ được cho lịch sử phát triển tương
lai của họ.
Dạ, của em xin hết ạ.
Đây là tài liệu thì mình cũng có tài liệu
ha,
nhưng mà còn về cái phần phạm vi em kéo
xuống cái trang,
phạm vi dự kiến đầu tư của các em á.
À keo cái này.
Dạ alo cơ.
Các em nghe câu nói chưa,
nghe câu nói không?
Kéo xuống cái trang phạm vi.
Cái kế hoạch dự kiến đầu tư của các em.
Được cô ơi.
Cái em không nghe cô nói hả? Ồ,
các bạn khác có nghe câu nói không vậy?
Cho em.
Đạt em tự chết lại cái mít của em đi,
bạn các bạn khác vẫn nghe câu nói mà.
Kéo xuống cái chỗ cái phần đầu tư em.
Rồi mở mắt lên trao đổi.
Cái cách mà các em trình bày trong cái
phần này của nhìn vô là có biết là chắc
mỗi bạn làm mỗi kiểu mà các em viết kiểu
này là cứ mỗi cái là các em sẽ có một cái
đối tượng đầu tư,
rồi có một cái thời gian.
À thực hiện riêng á là người ta sẽ hiểu
hành giống như cái em đang viết từ 5 dự
án khác nhau vậy đó.
Với lại cái 5 cái nhiều lắm,
cái mặc dù của em giới hạn rồi nó cũng
vẫn nhiều.
Nếu trong các cái phạm vi ghép đề tài các
nhóm trước đã báo cáo rồi á thì tầm đẹp
là các em dao động từ 2 đến 3 lớp thôi.
Trong đó mình có thể giả lập 2 thành phần
có sẵn rồi.
Mình đầu tư 3 thành phần còn lại của 2
lớp. Những lớp mình đã chọn ra được.
Chứ cái này nó rộng quá các em.
Biết sẽ rất là nhiều và nó không có mà
không có tìm hiểu sâu như một cái nào đâu.
Hình như ngon nhóm.
Về nhóm thảo luận và chọn lại đi hả em?
Dạ.
Ừ nhưng mà.
Còn ý tưởng và thực hành cái hình ảnh gì?
Thực hành ý tưởng thực hành thảo luận,
giờ có chọn đủ ý tưởng chưa?
Nhạc bài học hành,
tụi em cũng sẽ đi sâu vào FE và đầu tư
các hạ tầng công nghệ.
Vô phần mềm chế đầu tư hạ tầng công nghệ
gì đấy, nãy giờ không nghe hả?
tưởng.
Ý tưởng của bài thực hành là mình xây
dựng cái phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới
trong cái chat,
cô cũng đã nhắn lại rồi đó.
Nếu mà chưa chọn thì nhóm mình thảo luận
với nhau chọn luôn nha kem.
Ai thực hành của mình ở với thuyết minh
phát triển hệ thống phần mềm ứng dụng
công nghệ mới.
Mà cái công cái bài phần mềm của mình thì
nên trong cái phạm vi bài dự án đầu tư
bên mình, đồ án khoa học của mình.
Để cho nó có mang tính xuyên suốt.
Đâu hiểu không đạt.
Dạ dạ, và mình sẽ đi sau và phần mềm.
Còn yêu.
Ừ.
Chọn cái công nghệ mới,
anh ấy cô có giới thiệu với giới thiệu
một vài công nghệ mới rồi đó,
các em đi tìm hiểu công nghệ mới.
Hiện tại thì mình chưa có rảnh thì mình
cứ chọn công nghệ mới rồi trong một cái
phạm vi thôi,
xong đó là mình tìm hiểu từ từ rồi mình
sẽ cái bài mình nó cụ thể được.
Dạ, em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi.
Ừ, nhớ chính cái đó hả em?
Dạ
Dạ em cảm ơn cô.
Đợi.
Nhớ mãi, nhóm nào tăng?
Ôi nhóm 1 và là nhóm 1.
Nếu mà báo cáo thì cái.
Alo alo.
Nghe được 1 tiếng, nó hơi vọng với em.
Mic máy bị hỏng, em đang dùng 2 máy.
Tắt 1 máy, tắt mic, 1 máy.
Rồi nhóm 1 các em cập nhật đề thông tin
đề tài của mình chưa vậy?
Mình nhóm một cái đặc biệt là.
Sao cô không thấy ta?
lô.
Rồi nghe đỡ hơn rồi đó em.
Alo.
Mà mít to lên em, em nói cô nghe không rõ.
Ờ hiện tại em đang nghe em,
em đang nói bằng điện thoại nhưng nó sẽ
hơi khó tại vì cái mic của em nó bị hỏng
mất rồi.
Giờ bây giờ con nghe được rồi mà.
Giai đoạn đoạn để em chia sẻ màn hình.
Nhóm một của mình cập nhật đề tài chưa
sao cô dọn không thấy em.
Ở để em nhắn với lại em không phải ở bên
bên nắm giữ cái linh nên là.
Để em nhắn với các bạn,
để em đã các bạn cập nhật.
Nếu mình bữa trước,
nếu mình chưa khảo sát cơ bản,
Có bạn, bạn nói là cập nhật rồi.
bữa trước là cô mới hỏi là các em cầm
được chưa,
và các em replay cái mới hay sao?
Như là edit là cái cũ.
Cô đang ở đây nè, cô thấy của nhóm.
Dạ nhóm em Edit cũng.
Em mới dùng 1 kem có cập nhật gì là kem
lấy cái mới cho cô coi.
Bây giờ cô thấy rồi,
cái bắt đầu trình bày đi.
Được rồi,
em bắt đầu trình bày xíu thì bên bọn em
sẽ làm chủ yếu về công khảo sát,
bọn em sẽ làm về doanh nghiệp là công ty
phần mềm FPT.
Em đi sức khỏe và cái này công ty này khá
nổi tiếng ở Việt Nam rồi thì em sẽ bỏ qua
cái phần lịch sử phát triển xíu và đi đến
cái phần trọng tâm của mình luôn thì phạm
vi bài của bọn em sẽ tập trung vào phần
computer và data.
Là 2 cái lớp,
2 cái lớp chính của bọn em thì ở lớp công.
Về phần khái niệm thì lớp comput như
trước mình cũng đã học ấy là có khả năng
cung cấp, xử lý tính toán là cái a.
Nơi các ứng dụng dịch vụ tại tác vụ được
trải các thành phần tiêu biểu gồm các cái
Nãy mình coi nãy giờ,
nhóm mình có nghe báo cáo luôn các em.
máy chủ.
Sau giờ ngồi trình bày khái niệm,
đi thẳng vô luôn cái phạm vi em.
có.
Em em nói sơ qua xíu thôi nên nếu hơn cả
em sẽ vào phần năng lực này thì công ty
Ừ
FPT vận hành nền tảng đám mây FT Cloud
với hệ sinh thái em 80 giải pháp.
Theo tiêu chuẩn về đám mây quốc tế,
cung cấp cả máy chủ ảo và dịch vụ GPU cho
AI. Vào tháng 11 năm 2024 thì FPT Gamas,
FPT AI,
hạ tầng AI đầu và cũng là cuối cùng của
GPU in.
Invidia H200 Tanse Core với FPT và đối
tác đám mây ưu tiên à đến tháng 6 năm
2025, hai cụm FPT, AI Fastory lập mạng.
Các em hướng dẫn chưa vô nội dung các em,
cái này cô không có yêu cầu các em trình
bày về lịch sử,
các em chỉ cần nói về cái phạm vi một
trang trong một trang yêu cầu ngày hôm
nay là bài của mình,
chỉ cần output và một trang.
Nói về cái lớp mà các em điều kiến làm
thì các em có thể dành một cái đoạn ngắn
nói về cái ngữ cảnh hiện trạng hiện tại
của công ty FPT,
nó đã có các lớp năng lực nào hoặc các
thành phần nào đã được đầu tư hoàn thiện
rồi.
Và bây giờ kế hoạch dự kiến của nhóm là
các em sẽ đầu tư phát triển thêm các lớp
năng lực nào và sẽ chỉ đầu tư cho cái
thành phần nào thôi.
Thành Nhân Mông.
Ừ.
Rồi trình bày lại đi em.
Có.
Đây thì cái sản phẩm của bọn em sẽ đầu tư
nâng cao về hạ tầng computer data và phục
vụ phát triển và triển khai dịch vụ AI
của doanh nghiệp công nghệ thông tin này.
Bọn em sẽ đầu tư vào lớp compill và lớp
data.
Cho các nhân viên như ví dụ như kỹ sư AI,
data này, kỹ sư, debop hạ tầng, độ phát,
độ phát triển và ca các phòng ban gồm như
khối R and D,
các đơn vị kinh doanh làm dự án chuyển
đổi số.
Quản lý nguồn lực, quy trình,
quy trình hoạt động sẽ cùng quy trình
phát triển đến triển khai mô hình AI từ
data huấn luyện trên Campill và đưa vào
dịch vụ và quản lý dữ liệu dự án.
Ở.
Thời gian để thực hiện đề xuất đồ án cho
môn học thì giai đoạn đầu từ tuần 1 đến
tuần 3 bọn em sẽ khảo sát thực tập tài
liệu, phân tích hai lớp Compound và data.
Giai đoạn thứ 2 từ tuần 4 đến tuần 8,
mô hình kiến trúc.
Ở sẽ là bọn em sẽ làm về mô hình kiến
trúc,
đối chiếu năng lực công khai của FPT và
với phân tích hoàn thiện báo giai đoạn
cuối từ tuần 9 đến phần tầm 12,
bọn em sẽ hoàn cảnh báo cáo one-pay giờ
và danh sách tài liệu.
Cuối cùng là giá cuối cùng là rà soát lại
nguồn lại một lần nữa ờ phạm vi của bọn
em thì sẽ phân tích 2 lớp là comple và
data ở mức mô hình dựa trên dữ liệu công
khai và những gì trong ngoài phạm vi á
thì bọn em sẽ truy cập.
Dữ liệu hệ thống nội bộ thực tế của FPT
xây dựng hệ thống của Production.
Kết quả bọn em **** muốn thì báo cáo bọn
em sẽ muốn có được báo cáo khảo sát tổ
chức phân tích 2 lớp năng lực hạ tầng và
công ty của data.
Gojek Ons Onscope Project Coop One
Pateger và danh sách tài liệu tham khảo
và đây là transactic thôi.
Các em đọc hướng dẫn sao mà giờ ra cái
danh sách kỳ vọng kỳ vậy, cái này em.
Một cái dự án đầu tư mà sao làm một cái
one paper được?
Cái War Miper là cái sản phẩm bài tập lớp
trên lớp ngày hôm nay của mình đó.
Cái lúc mà các em ghi giai đoạn 3 là cô
cũng ghi rồi.
Cái quang Bayer và danh sách tài liệu
tham khảo là sản phẩm bài tập ngày hôm
Dạ dạ.
nay của mình á,
để các em được thực hiện cái đề tài đầu
tư dự án,
cái đầu tư dự án và một cái file báo cáo
làm sao một trang được.
Em mình luôn không.
Mày sai vấn đề ngay từ ban đầu luôn với
các nhóm phía trước nãy giờ là các bạn
cũng đã báo cáo sửa mẫu 4 5 nhóm rồi mà.
Hãy nhớ mình không có nghe đúng không?
Rồi bây giờ để nhóm mình kèm mở cái file
hướng dẫn thực hành như là file hướng dẫn
đồ án lên cho cô đi.
Rồi các em mở ngay chỗ kia yêu cầu để cô
chỉ cho nhóm còn lại và các em phải làm
lại cái này nha.
Nếu mà làm sai hết yêu cầu rồi.
Mở đứa em mở lên đây,
cô chỉ và nhóm mình nằm cập nhật lại.
Rồi để em xíu em.
Để em bảo anh Quyền Linh tại vì em đang
bên.
Dạ đây ạ.
Rồi thấy ông đi là sản phẩm là gì các em?
Yêu cầu sản phẩm hết trơn.
Đề xuất dự án.
Ừ, mở ngoặc nó là một cái file.
Báo cáo
Phải báo cáo rồi khi thuyết trình thì các
em có soạn thêm một cái gì nữa.
Slime báo cáo, bây giờ báo cáo.
Còn cái bài tập ngày hôm nay của mình là
cái bài tập xác định phạm vi đề xuất và
cái one Bayer của mình á thấy không?
Hai cái sản phẩm đầu ra ở mức không luôn.
Cái một trang ngày hôm nay là cái một
trang miêu tả về cái sản phẩm mà mình
phạm vi đề xuất mà mình dự kiến làm.
Ừ và ở đây là tôi thấy cái em chọn 2 lớp
đầu tư trong 2 lớp năng lực rồi lớp số 1
và lớp số 5 đúng không?
C mạnh.
Ừ, phải kem viết lại cho đúng.
Ra đây,
các em có cái định giả lập làm mình sẽ
đầu tư các thành phần nào trong 2 lớp
năng lực này không hay là đầu tư hết.
Biết bạn ánh xạ luôn.
Tr.
Biết bạn đánh xạ luôn.
Ăn anh.
Bản xã trong chương 2.
Mặc áo xa chương 2 lên.
Bọn em là định đầu tư một phần ở trong
này thôi.
Một phần là cái nào cô thấy nhóm mình
không biết rõ nên cô mới kêu cầu cho em
mở size lên đây cô chỉ để mình không có
tự chế lan man.
Sau này tới lúc làm sai là không có điểm.
Mã sao đây chưa anh em.
Đó là chân không em,
em biết chân hay chân số mấy luôn.
Số 2 đó.
Đó, bạn xạ đó em mới vừa kéo qua đó.
Bây giờ kem chọn 2 lớp năng lực rồi đúng
không? Top 1 với top số 5.
Bây giờ mình sẽ chọn tiếp coi mình đầu tư
hết tất cả các thành phần trong hai lớp
này, chỉ với hạng 2, 3 năm,
2 3 thành phần thôi.
Thì nếu mình phải thảo luận với nhau và
chọn lại. Hiểu ý của nó chưa?
Ừ.
Bọn em sẽ gặp lại bọn em bạn lại ạ.
Rồi bây giờ mở tiếp file hướng dẫn thực
hành.
Hướng dẫn thực hành là mình sẽ xây dựng
cái thuyết minh.
Cho cái phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới.
Hướng dẫn thực hành.
Vô cái thực hành vô thực hành.
Ở.
Do folder thực hành nữa em.
Số 2 á.
Cái founder máy này máy này không có.
Cô đưa lên drive tài liệu trên Elonin rồi
em.
Kéo lên trên cùng đó.
Thuyết minh của mình là xây dựng hệ thống
phần mềm thấy không?
Dạ.
Trong cái phạm vi đồ án của em,
thì các em chọn hệ thống phần mềm liên
quan trong phạm vi đồ án của mình,
tìm hiểu một công nghệ mới và lên kế
hoạch xây dựng thuyết minh đề tài phần
mềm.
Còn ý tưởng nãy giờ thì cô có sửa cho vài
nhóm rồi,
lát hồi nhóm mình coi video lại rồi nhóm
mình thảo luận chứ không nằm,
nếu mình mà các em không có,
không xác định rõ mấy cái nội dung hướng
chuẩn này là các em làm sai yêu cầu á.
Rồi cô nhóm 1 cô hay like lại nha.
tôi.
Bố cô tôi cái báo cáo tính chuẩn để cô sẽ
kiểm tra lại.
Rồi được rồi em.
Nhóm tiếp theo hơn.
Nhóm 8 em.
alo.
Ừ.
Nhóm 8 em thì sau khi cô ấy thì em xác
định lại á thì nhóm em làm về xây dựng hệ
thống metro để.
Ở nâng cấp thể thông với Port sang sale
check out.
Thì bối cảnh.
Hoàng là bây giờ là bây giờ của mình là
đồ án của các em đang nói về đồ án hay là
bài thực hành.
Dạ, em nói đồ đồ án luôn.
Đồ án là mình sẽ bắt đầu từ cái lớp năng
lực đầu tư chứ tại sao lại bắt đầu từ hệ
thống?
Ở nếu mà lớp năng lực đầu tư thì nhóm em
chọn 3 lớp, lớp 1 là còn.
Lớp một hạ tầng lớp 4 là app ứng dụng và
nền tảng tích hợp và lớp 5 là nền tảng
của phạm vi.
Rồi tại sao mình chọn 5 cái lớp này,
công ty này đang có vấn đề gì mà mình cần
phải phát triển 3 lớp năng lực này?
Ở.
Về bối cảnh thì bọn em giả định là cái hệ
thống bán hàng hiện tại thì họ đang bị
quá tải trong thời gian.
Ở.
Trong cái thời gian tăng cao,
ví dụ như dịp nghỉ lễ Tết thì khách hàng
tăng cao thì bây giờ nhân viên và quầy
thu ngân nó sẽ bị ùn ứ.
Thì bây giờ công ty **** muốn là có một
giải pháp để mà giảm tải cho hệ thống thu
ngân và tăng trải nghiệm khách hàng lên
thì bọn em sẽ có cái hệ thống đang chạy
của Lotte Mart là khách hàng chỉ cần lấy
món đồ đó.
Và.
Quét lên mã và thanh toán thôi thì nó sẽ
không cần phải đến quầy thương ngân nữa
thì giảm tải cho hệ thống thu ngân và
trải nghiệm khách hàng sẽ tốt hơn.
Em cũng đang giả định là lớp một thì cái
này lớp một là hệ thống của họ đang sử
dụng firewall.
Nhưng mà phải quên đời cũ thì yêu cầu về
chi phí vận hành rất là cao và yêu cầu
một đội ngũ IT phải có mức lương cũng cấu
hình rất là khó.
Thì bây giờ nên **** muốn là đầu tư hệ
thống hạ tầng nó cao hơn,
nó có băng thông lớn hơn và.
Hệ thống file và các hệ thống file nằm
bên dưới và hệ thống cáp quang saotuside
nó dễ vận hành hơn cho đội ngũ IT để.
Giảm cái chi phí vận hành xuống.
Và nền tảng platform này thì ý tưởng của
bọn em **** muốn cô là cho em thì ý tưởng
bọn em là dùng cái nền tảng báo cáo này,
ví dụ như cấp ca.
Ờ và data way house để hoặc là powerbi
thì ờ đặt đặt cái vị trí của cái máy post
đó ở đúng vị trí,
ví dụ như hành vi khách hàng để phân tích
cái dữ liệu là đặt ở vị trí a,
vị trí b hoặc là.
Giống như là đặt ở quầy đâu sống hay là
đặt ở quầy nhựa gì đó thì dạ.
Năm nè.
Có nghĩa là nhóm thành nhân,
cô sẽ highlight với mình,
cô có thời gian coi lại nha.
Nếu mình trao đổi lại thì các em.
Thứ nhất là khi mà các em chọn phạm vi đồ
án.
Làm cái em chọn vấn đề á thì mình nên
chọn một vấn đề và cái vấn đề đó muốn cải
thiện thì nó sẽ luôn phải cần cải thiện
các lớp lêu nào. Khi các em đặt cái vấn,
đặt các bài toán theo kiểu như vậy thì nó
thứ nhất, phạm vi nó sẽ không,
nó sẽ cụ thể.
Nó không bị lan man theo kiểu là mình
phải đầu tư hết toàn bộ cái hạ tầng và nó
có tính liền mạch là mình phải đầu tư
nhiều lớp và kết hợp với nhau để giải
quyết cùng một vấn đề hoặc là các cái lớp
này nó có mối liên kết với nhau nên chúng
nên.
Đầu tư và sau khi đầu tư xong rồi thì nó
sẽ nâng cấp cái quy trình cải thiện cái
quy trình hoạt động của công ty lên luôn,
còn 3 cái lớp mà các em trình bày nãy giờ
và cách cái em trình bày á nó đang bị rời
với nhau,
không có cái nào dính với cái nào hết á.
Với lại cái ý đầu tiên,
cái đầu tiên mà các em nói gọi là tự quét
mã tự thanh toán theo kiểu.
Hệ thống siêu thị thông minh.
Mỗi cái app không có đủ sạc,
không có đủ phát triển thôi các em.
Cái đó là nó giống như các em chuyển đổi
hệ sinh thái luôn rồi á.
Lớn lắm nè,
cái và và cái kiểu mà tự quét thì cũng.
Thứ nhất là giống như kiểu châu Âu là nó
sẽ có các quầy và không có thu ngân và tự
mua rồi tự quét mã rồi thanh toán,
tự đi ra.
Thì đó là cái cái đó mình đổi theo hệ
sinh thái và khi đó là nó liên quan tới
cái thói quen của người dùng nữa chứ
không phải mình muốn đổi là đổi được.
Là giống như ở châu Âu là người ta có
thói quen mua hàng như vậy thì và có tất
cả các thiết bị hệ sinh thái đáp ứng đủ
thì mình làm hoặc là một cái hướng siêu
dạ.
thị thứ hai.
Là kiểu lấy ra.
Tự thanh toán trên thẻ Visa luôn,
không còn quét gì hết,
chỉ cần lấy mặt hàng ra khỏi tủ là nó sẽ
từ trừ để lại thì nó sẽ cộng lại.
Nó có một cái loại phương thức theo kiểu
đó nữa và cái,
nhưng mà nếu mà làm theo kiểu đó là giống
như mình đổi hệ sinh thái của cái phương
thức hoạt động của công ty luôn á.
Dạ,
cái ý tưởng này và cho em nói xíu là cái
Kiểu đó là thì kiểu lớn á.
ý tưởng này thì có anh làm ở trong Lotte
thì anh đang làm ở trong công ty để anh
nói là Lotte đang áp dụng cái này thì ví
dụ những mặt hàng nào mà kiểu.
Định giá sẵn luôn chứ không phải mặt hàng
mà tươi sống hay cân ký cân nặng á thì
không được,
nhưng mà họ sẽ dám một cái mã lên đó và
quét lên thì nó sẽ tính tiền đó thì theo
quy trình là như vậy.
Thì anh mới chọn cái đề tài dạ.
Thì bây giờ,
nếu mà em làm một cái đó thì em làm một
cái thôi.
Ở đây kem 3 mỗi lớp,
em em mỗi lớp nãy giờ em trình bày.
Mỗi lớp là em chơi là mỗi lớp em nêu ra
một vấn đề, leo một. Em những vấn đề này,
leo bốn giải quyết vấn đề kia,
lên 5 giải quyết vấn đề nọ.
Nó bị ròi á.
Ví dụ,
nhóm cái đó là các em chọn một cái thì
À
các em chọn đúng cái chủ đề đó luôn thì
đó đi đôi là phần cứng,
phần mềm và làm cái vấn đề về bảo mật đi
kèm luôn.
Và một người trong quá trình thanh toán
luôn,
tại nó liên quan thứ nhất là em còn phải
có thiết bị đeo hết,
thiết bị phần cứng họ ra đủ để cho có thể
tự thanh toán và chuyển hình thức tự động
nhiều hơn.
Rồi và nó có khả năng xử lý dữ liệu nhanh
hơn.
Cái thứ 2 á là nó sẽ có kết nối và nó xử
lý một cách an toàn hơn.
Tại vì cho cái người dùng xử lý chứ không
phải nhân viên của mình.
Nên nếu mà nó phải giảm thiểu sự cố nhất
có thể hay là an toàn nhất thì người ta
mới sử dụng cái đó chẳng hạn.
Thì em chọn đúng một cái vấn đề và em đẩy
hết tất cả các đầu tư, tất cả các lớp,
Dạ.
các thành phần của lớp liên quan tới cái
vấn đề mà các em muốn nói thôi.
Phải là bị tham quá luôn cô.
Đúng rồi, vô vô một cái thôi,
thí dụ giống như các nhóm hồi nãy có một
Dạ.
nhóm hình như nói về vấn đề dữ liệu là sẽ
dữ liệu giữa các cái chi nhánh nó chưa
đồng bộ, nó dẫn đến cái vấn đề bất cập.
Là thông tin nó chưa có đồng bộ hóa nên
trải nghiệm người dùng nó bị thấp là có
thể là tới nơi nó mới biết phát hiện được
chi nhánh này hết hàng rồi.
Nó chưa cập nhật lên hoặc là nếu mà có
chi nhánh có hàng khác thì cái chi nhánh
bên đây nó cũng khó lắm.
Xin để mình có thể nhận chuyển hàng qua
tại vì dữ liệu đó chưa cập nhật đồng bộ,
chẳng hạn cái vấn đề đó vấn đề đặt ra thì
bây giờ bạn mình sẽ đầu tư hạ tầng giải
quyết cái vấn đề nào đồng bộ hóa dữ liệu
cho tất cả các quy trình nào đó.
Thì khi đó là mình sẽ đầu tư các lớp từ
hạ tầng ứng dụng và lớp dữ liệu chẳng hạn
cũng như mà chị giải quyết vấn đề đó thôi
thì các em chọn một cái.
Ừ
Dạ tại vì em nhóm em thì có em 2 bạn nữa
thì làm hạ tầng thì cái đầu tư hạ tầng là
thì biết xong rồi.
Tại vì có 12 người nên sẽ có phần app này
thì sợ là nó ít quá nữa.
Cô đánh giá thấp thôi,
nên mấy bạn chọn thêm phần năm này ấy
Không phải là nhiều hay ít, các em,
các em làm và các em hiểu rõ vấn đề và
được.
Dạ.
cái bài đầu tư của em liền mạch thì nó
mới được giá cao. Chứ đâu phải làm nhiều,
Dạ.
mà các em bài của các em là Mạnh An đi
làm và nó không có sự liền mạch á.
Cái dự án đó nó không được đánh giá cao
đâu.
Làm nó làm trong một team là mình phải có
sự hợp tác và nắm được cái luồng và nó có
được liên kết.
Ngay cả cái dự án mà kiểu cụm nhiệm vụ
hoặc là chủ nhiệm vụ lớn hiện tại mới mở
hiện tại cô đang tham gia đó.
Nó mặc dù là nó có nhiều nhiệm vụ nhưng
mà lúc nào nó cũng sẽ bắt.
Câu là mối quan hệ giữa các các cái nhiệm
vụ đang có thì nó mới gom là thành một
cọng hoặc một chuỗi nhiệm vụ đó và đầu tư.
Tại vì khi mà em triển khai thì nó đòi
hỏi về cái năng lực của cái nhóm đó nữa.
Năng lực chuyên môn của các nhóm liên
quan thì các cái chủ nhiệm vụ của em nó
phải liên quan với nhau và trong cùng một
cái vấn đề,
một lĩnh vực nào đó thì người ta mới giao,
với người ta mới tự tin giao cho mình
được.
Tôi phải chuyên biệt lại.
Và cái vấn đề này là các nhóm phía trước
đã trình bày rồi,
nếu mình không chú ý nghe ha.
hơi tham.
Ừ.
Rồi chọn lại xong rồi tới cái bài thực
hành cũng vậy, vô một cái hệ thống,
một quy trình, một hệ thống phần mềm,
một công nghệ mới giải quyết một vấn đề
thôi mà hoặc 2 vấn đề.
Nếu mà nó có tốt thì hoặc là với 2 vấn đề
chứ đừng tham nhiều quá.
Cái cần phải hiểu rõ về kỹ thuật và cách
thức triển khai. Mình không có triển khai,
nhưng mà các em biết là nếu triển khai
thì mình sẽ có phải sử dụng,
phải xảy ra các bước nào và mình có các
kỹ thuật nào sẽ triển khai ra.
Giúp giải quyết vấn đề đó.
Hải năng sẽ được đánh giá cao hơn là mình
viết theo kiểu lan man chung chung,
viết lan man chung chung,
có nghĩa là mình không biết gì hết á.
Nói thì được,
nhưng mà triển khai không được.
Cái đó là cái kỵ nhất của cái thuyết minh
dưới đó,
cái hạ tầng đầu tư mình mà viết theo kiểu
đó bị đánh rớt liền luôn á.
Hư rồi cô hai lại rồi nhóm mình chỉnh sửa
rồi mốt tới cái đặt báo cáo định kỳ thì
cô sẽ coi lại sao hết.
Tiền.
Rồi nhóm tiếp theo ha.
Nh 7
Rồi kem bắt đầu đi kim.
Dạ có thấy màn hình em ngồi đúng không ạ?
Rồi cô thấy rồi.
Dạ rồi em xin phép bắt đầu thì nhóm 7 của
em chọn đề tài là kẻng tân cảng ở cảng
Cát Lái.
Đây thì đồ án của tụi em sẽ là nâng cao
cái năng lực vận hành của hạ tầng công
nghệ thông tin phục vụ cho cảng ở các lái
và cái lớp năng lực của tụi em lựa chọn
dự kiến là lớp số 2.
Nên là uploadform và là cái lớp.
Đóng vai trò các lớp còn lại đóng vai trò
giống như là hỗ trợ thôi.
Lý do nhóm chọn đề tài này thì hiện tại
là ở cảng tân cảng đang có những cái hệ
thống.
Như là quản lý khai thác cảng rồi quản lý
cái dữ liệu của container rồi quản lý
luồng ra vào của tài xế thì khi mà các
dịch vụ công nghệ thông tin mà nó bị lỗi.
Nó phản hồi chậm thì nó sẽ ảnh hưởng tới
những cái á.
Ở
Thành phần khác của của của cho một cái
hệ thống nên là.
Nhóm ưu tiên cái khả năng giám sát,
phát hiện và xử lý,
phục hồi cái năng lực công nghệ thông tin.
Các hạng mục đầu tư chính sẽ là bao gồm
là cái monitor và of serverbity,
bao gồm là có xây dựng các nền tảng giám
sát tập trung.
Cho server để sân bay network AB tích hợp
và của các cái hệ thống mạ cản đã có.
Theo dõi các cái chỉ số như là AVIDT, CPU,
RAM,
độ trễ của mạng và đo lường thời gian của
API cũng như là.
Ở thời gian kết nối người ta bày.
Mục tiêu là để phát hiện những cái bất
thường trước khi mà sự cố ảnh hưởng tới
cái việc mà vận hành của cảng.
Rồi tiếp theo sẽ là các cái chỉ số KPI.
Thế.
Cái đó mình không cần game,
các em chỉ cần nói về các lớp năng lực
Quản lý cái việc.
thôi.
Xong rồi viết tất nhiên sách tài liệu.
Dạ rồi.
Dạ thì danh sách tài liệu thì ờ.
Tụi em có tham khảo trang chủ của cả các
lái chính đó.
Các em phải thống kê lại các cái nguồn
tài liệu trong cái file của mình để book
mình làm cái ví dụ cái đó là cái nguồn
nào đó mà list ra chứ.
dạ.
Tay.
Nhớ cái tài liệu ư.
Dạ.
Rồi vậy.
Em sẽ phép mắt được.
C tại.
Bà thực hành đúng không? Ok,
cô nên hỏi đó tao trình bày đi.
Thực.
Dạ.
Dạ rồi.
Giờ thì cái dựa trên cái.
Thì bài kiến thực hành của nhóm sẽ lựa
chọn là báo cáo cái lưu lượng và hỗ trợ
điều phối hoạt động của cảng Cát Lái,
bài toán sẽ là.
Ở lưu lượng phương tiện và container của
cảng thay đổi theo từng thời điểm thì nếu
mà có khả năng dự báo trước thì sẽ phát
hiện những cái khung giờ mà nó cao tải để
mà kiểm soát cái việc mà tránh ùn tắc.
Ờ thì ờ giảm một tắc thì cũng có nghĩa là
ờ giảm.
Gọi là tiết kiệm được tài nguyên cho cho
cho cảng cũng như là cho các cái bên đối
tác của của hãng tàu cũng như là những
người mà nhập hàng rồi.
Ý tưởng là sẽ là ở hệ thống đi thu thập
dữ liệu và vận hành hiện có của cảng bao
gồm là thời gian xe vào và ra nhưng cái
số lượng phương tiện, số lượng container.
Các cái loại à nghiệp vụ,
thời gian xử lý ở khu vực bãi và lưu
lượng theo khung giờ.
xử lý.
Dữ liệu vận hành sẽ là thu thập tiền xử
lý báo cáo lưu lượng,
sau đó sẽ đổ data về dashboard và cuối
cùng là nếu mà có những cái cảnh báo thì
sẽ hiện cho những cái người mà chỉ trích.
Trách nhiệm.
Và công nghệ mà nhóm dự kiến áp dụng sẽ
bao gồm là AI để mà dự báo được cái lưu
lượng mắc tải reetime data processing để
mà xử lý những cái dữ liệu.
Ở thời gian thực và ở.
Trao đổi dữ liệu với các thành phần giữa
các cái hệ thống và cảng đã có và cuối
cùng là đã tạo anh la ladit để trực quan
hóa những cái dữ liệu để mà biến thành
những cái báo cáo.
Ý tưởng của nhóm của ông Á kêu.
Nhưng mà ở đây em chúc em trình bày em có
cảm giác là em không có phân biệt được từ
dự báo với từ báo cáo.
Trên đây cái em ghi dự báo mà đất nấu một
hồi các em thành báo cáo.
Các em phải phân biệt được nó,
thí dụ một ứng dụng BI bình thường,
xuất báo cáo.
Thì nó dựa trên cái dữ liệu thống kê và
datbo rồi mình xuất báo cáo thôi chứ hỗ
trợ phân tích.
Khai thác dữ liệu phân tích bình thường
thôi chứ chưa có phải là ứng dụng AI dự
báo gì cả,
còn khi mà em ghi dùng từ dự báo lưu
lượng á thì nó sẽ chuyển ra một cái nó
chuyển thành một cái bài toán ứng dụng
thời gian tạo khác.
Cứ một bài toán dụng giấy tờ nhân tạo mở
rộng hơn.
Nếu mà nếu mà hiểu đúng về dự báo lưu
lượng á ở đây thì gọi là dự báo,
dự báo và báo cáo khác nhau.
Dự báo lưu lượng có nghĩa là.
Mình sẽ dự báo lưu lượng trong theo tuần
hoặc là theo theo tuần quý mới để mình
đưa ra cái chiến lược điều phối phù hợp
nếu mình đặt cái bối cảnh kiểu đó thì nó
sẽ phối thì nó.
Nó sẽ nghe nó hay hơn và lúc em trình bày
nó bị đừng có nhầm lẫn cả lúc mà trong
cái phần mà cái em đưa lên dự kiến thì cô
hiểu thôi cái bài toán đó đúng không?
Dạ vâng.
Về các bước luồng xử lý cơ bản thì cũng
ổn, nhưng mà ở đây cô góp ý thêm ha.
Nếu mà các em đã chọn bài toán phù hợp
rồi thì các em nên đi tìm hiểu kỹ về cái
bài toán kỹ thuật và cái dữ liệu xử lý
các em.
Và cái bài toán dự báo năng lượng là thực
chất là cái bài toán hồi quy thôi mà quy
giá trị.
Ừm theo xem series.
Nó còn giống,
cần động chất với cái bài toán dự báo giá
cổ phiếu giá coin thông qua các cơ sở
Windows á Windows Time á.
Dạ.
Thì mình nên tìm hiểu kỹ về các kỹ thuật
đó để mình có thể trình bày vô đây và thứ
nhất là cái thứ 2 là cái mở rộng cái dữ
liệu,
cái dữ liệu mà các em đang liệt kê này
nãy giờ ở đây là dữ liệu dạng bản dựa
trên các cái thông tin.
Gọi là dữ liệu nội tại bình thường của hệ
thống thôi,
còn cái số liệu hiện tại là bên cạnh khai
thác dữ liệu.
Của hệ thống thì người ta sẽ có cặp cho
các thông tin khai thác dữ liệu mở rộng
khác. Từ Big Dater trên internet á.
Để có thể tiến hành dự báo chính xác hơn
tại vì mình không phải dự báo trong xu
hướng gần mà mình có thể dự báo trong xu
hướng xa để lên kế hoạch.
Tại vì cảng thì quy mô nó cao chứ nó
không phải giống như giá cổ phiếu giá
coin mình mua theo gọi là trading.
Thì mình có thể dự báo trong khoảng thời
gian ngắn, còn ở đây,
nếu mà cái mức vận hành thường người ta
sẽ yêu cầu dự báo ở trong khoảng thời
gian xa hơn.
Thì mới kịp điều phối được.
Chứ mình dự báo chỉ bị dự báo trước 1
ngày thì mình khó khó điều phối lắm đó
Dạ.
nha.
Dạ, đem nó lại.
Đúng không, cái đó là tốt ý của con.
Dạ.
Rồi những tiếp theo.
Các chính sách taxi.
Những.
Nếu mà những ngày của anh nhớ máy ta.
Nhóm 7 sao, nhóm 7 nhóm nào đăng ký.
Sao nhóm 7 không có nhóm đăng ký mới thì
cô gọi đây theo các nhóm còn lại.
Nhưng 4 lần rồi nhóm 4 lên đi em.
Nếu muốn em đăng ký đề tài chưa?
Dạ rồi cô.
Đề tài của các em là cái gì?
Cái câu nhỏ.
Dạ FPT Long Châu, cô.
Đúng rồi,
hồi nãy nhớ hồi nãy cô quên cái em đổi đề
tài nhóm 7 đổi đề tài thì lây cái mới,
cái edit rồi trên đó nó đâu có báo cho em.
Các em hình dung cái nào mà cô đã đánh
dấu rồi, có nghĩa là cô sẽ không coi lại.
Các em có muốn làm cái gì mới là các em
phải lấy cái mới ha.
Cô thấy nhóm 4 là cô chưa tương tác.
Nhóm 4 là.
FPT Long Châu rồi.
Dạ, đúng rồi cô.
Nãy có nhóm nào đâu đấy với Ti rồi ta có
trùng luôn nha. FPT subware đúng không?
FPT Lâm Châu.
Rồi được rồi, bắt đầu nè em.
Gia đình của đời em xíu.
Nhiếm chính có bạn đang đi học không?
Núm chính chuẩn bị nha,
nhóm em nhóm cuối cùng rồi đó.
Dạ có ạ.
Những chính.
Nhóm 4 xong rồi tới nhóm chính.
Có đợi em xíu nha thì em đang sao mà em
đang không share được cái màn hình của em.
Tích vô lúc xe chọn vô cái cửa sổ xuống
xe,
nó mới hiện cái nút để cho mình xe nha.
Rồi có thấy thấy màn hình em rồi.
Dô ừm trình bày đi.
vậy.
Và giờ cho xin phép nhóm em trình bày và.
À doanh nghiệp mà tụi em tụi em sẽ tìm
hiểu đó là FPT Long Châu ạ.
Ờ thì thôi kéo lên đầu xíu.
Trên chỉ đào.
Rồi trước khi mà bắt đầu vô cái phần đó
là nhóm em sẽ đầu tư vào cái phần lớp
năng lực nào vậy thì em xin phép được nói
sơ qua về cái lịch sử phát triển của FPT
Long Châu một chút xíu.
Vô hẳn nội dung luôn em hồi nãy cô mới
nhất.
Vô hạng nội dung thôi, em FPT Long Châu,
mọi người biết nè.
Em chỉ nói mưa ta có thể miêu tả ngắn gọn
nếu mà em muốn dẫn vô miêu tả ngắn gọn về
cái ngữ cảnh và cái hiện trạng ở công ty
đó,
cái vấn đề nào đang tồn tại và em muốn
đầu tư vào đâu thôi là được.
Nếu hơn.
Hình.
Bạn đang trình bày.
Thì đang thắc mắc đấy em.
À,
giá bán Long trình bày em xe hộ tại bạn
Long. Hiện tại không có xe được cái file.
Cái mức của Long có nói không,
sao con không nghe.
À dạ,
cô chắc mít của bạn Long có vấn đề một tí
nên em xin phép em trình bày qua cái.
Đề tài của nhóm em thì là đồ nhóm cái vấn
đề của nhóm em á là hệ thống Long Châu
Ừ
thì gồm rất nhiều nhà thuốc thì các nguồn
dữ liệu của nhà thuốc là nó còn rời rạc,
chưa có.
Còn nhớ theo thời gian thực thì làm giảm
độ chính xác của cái bộ dữ liệu đó đi.
Nhóm em.
Sẽ.
Hiện đề xuất 2 lớp năng lực đầu tư 2 lớp
năng lực, nhóm nhất là lớp.
Hạ tầng về mạng, về network là sẽ.
Từ những hệ thống mạng diện rộng,
wifi và đường truyền,
cái phần này do tụi em vừa mới tìm hiểu,
chưa có đào sâu vào.
Tụi em sẽ tìm hiểu sâu hơn về cái phần
network này sao.
Cái lớp đầu tư chính của tụi em là sẽ lớp
nền tảng dữ liệu.
Thì tôi em sẽ đầu tư vào cái phần thẩm
nhất dữ liệu vận hành.
Thì dựa vào cái công nghệ mới hiện tại
như là stream data,
stream ứng dụng Kefka và một số.
Công nghệ mới để đồng bộ dữ liệu từ các
kho kho và các cửa hàng về hệ thống data
đi house,
data wohel thì cái hệ thống nền tảng dữ
liệu này sẽ làm cái nền tảng để.
Đấy đấy, nhà hút có thể.
Thì nhà Phúc có thể tích hợp thêm cái mô
hình.
Phần này có thể làm nàng là làm cho các
mô hình AI,
tích hợp các mô hình AI dựa vào cái hàm
số mà đã được đào tạo để dự báo về cái
nhu cầu mà.
Số lượng hàng,
hàng tồn kho ở hàng sắp hết hạn giữa các
chi nhánh với nhau và giữa các kho và
giữa kho và chi nhánh để tối ưu việc quản
lý tồn kho.
Thì.
Cái lớp năng lực này chủ yếu là sẽ được
sử dụng cho.
Cho các đối tượng là khối vận hành hệ
thống thì sẽ trực tiếp giám sát được cái.
Cái nguồn dữ liệu nó sẽ tin cậy hơn khi
mà cái lớp nhóm network này nó được đầu
tư tốt.
Dữ liệu lúc đó sẽ được đồng bộ hóa kịp
thời, nhanh chóng và.
Những báo cáo thì chúng ta sẽ xây dựng
những báo cáo thời gian thực.
Đó là các các.
Bóng banh vậy
Vì cái khối vận hành thì các phòng ban về
vận kho thì chúng ta sẽ dựa trên cái nền
tảng data của chúng ta đã xây dựng.
Thì chúng ta sẽ tích hợp vào những cái hệ
thống quản trị có sẵn của hệ thống Long
Châu để xây dựng những cái lớp, những cái.
Màn hình cảnh báo về thời gian thực về
cái.
Các thông tin hàng hóa của các kho và các
chi nhánh, ví dụ như là.
Ở kho ở kho hiện tại đang có rất nhiều
hàng và thuốc này mà cái kho kho B á thì
hiện tại đang hết hàng thì chúng ta sẽ.
Đề xuất cho người vận hành đó thì ra
quyết định nhanh hơn về nhập kho và xuất
kho để làm đơn vận chuyển.
Ở cái việc nâng cấp hệ thống network và
data platform này cũng giúp cho.
Ban điều hành và hội đồng quản trị thì về
kế toán thì có thể.
Hãy theo dõi được hiệu quả kinh doanh
theo từng thời gian thực và ra quyết định
nhanh hơn, nhanh hơn trong hệ thống.
Cái quy trình chính và tụi em đầu tư thì
nó sẽ là những dữ liệu bán hàng và tồn
kho, xuất nhập kho của các kho hàng,
các cửa hàng thì sẽ được đồng bộ về data
của Heo.
Dữ liệu datawy Health này sẽ được sử dụng
để làm báo cáo các báo cáo tổng hợp và
mục tiêu chính của tụi em là ứng dụng AI.
Để phân tích dựa trên cái thời gian dữ
liệu thời gian thực này.
À để
Thì tính toán cái lượng hàng hoặc là cái
từ kho nào sang kho nào sẽ nhanh nhất để
tối ưu cái việc điều chỉnh kho hàng này
và.
Đưa đề xuất đến người quản trị và vận
hành để người vận hành có thể ra được
quyết định nhanh hơn.
Trong cái việc vận hành hệ thống kho.
Đó là cái ý tưởng và thực hành của các em
đúng không?
Thì dạ đúng rồi, cô về hành bài hành này,
tụi em sẽ đầu tư vào công nghệ đó là công
nghệ chính là AI và các việc đồng bộ dữ
liệu giữa các kho hàng.
Vậy data của heo.
Tem
Cái này đang nói quy trình tính của cái
gì của đồ án hả?
Dạ đoán.
Đồ án của em mình là đầu tư hạ tầng cơ sở
thông tin về các thành phần mà nó đâu có
quy định.
vô một cái,
nó đâu phải là một cái hệ thống phần mềm
hay là một quy trình cụ thể đâu các em.
Em mình bài thực hành của bài đâu quán
môn học của mình là cái em đầu tư để nâng
cao lớp năng lực đó và nó có thể phạm vi
ảnh hưởng nó sẽ rộng hơn đến các em.
Và nâng cao nguyên toàn bộ lớp năng lực
của công ty đó.
Giải quyết tất cả các vấn đề trong các
lớp năng lực mà các em đang chọn á.
Và nó có thể ảnh hưởng lên nhiều quy
trình khác nhau.
Dạ.
Dạ,
vậy chỗ này tụi em sẽ để cái đề tài hiện
tại là thực hành,
tụi em sẽ tìm hiểu sâu hơn về cái lớp
nick,
network và data này để ứng dụng cho các
quy trình khác nữa.
Thì hả
Thế làm cái bài đồ án nhất không?
Còn làm video em chứ không phải là các
lớp thêm vụ quy trình.
Cái mình dùng cái bài thực hành của mình,
cái bài đồ án hòa của mình giống như là
bây giờ ngữ cảnh này.
Thí dụ khoa bây giờ khoa muốn phát triển
hệ một cái phòng thí nghiệm.
Thì mình cần phải đầu tư cơ sở hạ tầng để
phát triển cái phòng thí nghiệm nó mới mở
được cái phòng thí nghiệm đó.
Nếu mà cái phòng thí nghiệm nó chưa có gì
hết thì mình phải đầu tư đầy đầy đủ hết
năm lớp năng lực luôn và hết tất cả các
thành phần luôn. Nhưng mà do.
Phòng thí nghiệm ở của trường.
Và nó ở của khoa rồi trực trực thuộc
trường ngoài trường.
Nó đã có một số cơ sở hạ tầng về đi tôi
sinh tơ về phần cứng tạo nguyên mạng đã
được đầu thụt sẵn rồi.
Và bây giờ mình chỉ cần bổ sung thêm một
số cái lớp năng lực để mình có thể vận
hành, có cái này,
có cái nào tái sử dụng được của trường
thì mình tái sử dụng lại. Còn thí dụ,
ví dụ giống như phần cứng đi thì có một
vài phần cứng nó đã có tồn tại.
Rồi nhưng mà nó bây giờ là bên phòng thí
nghiệm,
nó muốn mở thêm kỳ cho cái nhu cầu quy
trình hoạt động riêng của phòng thí
nghiệm thì mình đầu tư thêm.
Còn cái này dùng chung được của trường
thì mình dùng chung.
Cảm ơn phần mềm cũng vậy.
Bên hạ tầng bên dữ liệu,
hạ tầng nguyên mạng cũng vậy luôn chẳng
hạn.
Thì cái cái phần mà đồ án màu của các em
nó sẽ còn giống như vậy á.
Và các em sẽ đầu tư nhưng mà ở đây thì
nếu mà gọi là đầu tư mới hết toàn bộ lại
thì nó rộng quá nên cô mới cho các em
chọn một vài lớp năng lực để các em đầu
tư thôi.
Nó có thể là trong đó các em có thể vừa
đầu tư phần cứng vừa đầu tư để phát triển
và phần mềm quản trị, chẳng hạn.
Còn đối với cái bài thực hành thì các em
chọn vô một cái phần mềm ứng dụng công
nghệ mới rõ cụ thể giống như giả sử ở đây,
các em chọn một cái quy trình chính ở đây
là các em đang đầu tư một cái hệ thống
phần mềm vô một cái quy trình cụ thể.
Thí dụ quản lý kho.
Nhưng mà cái bài mà các em muốn nói nãy
giờ thì các em thật sự là nghe nhưng mà
biết là các em chưa có rành về cái này á.
Ví dụ quản lý kho,
các em chọn một cái bài toán dự đoán dự
báo, dự báo nhu cầu, nhu cầu.
Tồn kho hoặc là nhu cầu lưu lượng lưu
lượng vẫn dự báo về lưu lượng đi lưu
lượng hàng để mình có thể điều phối hàng
hóa giữa các kho mình chủ động điều phối
trước khi nó bị tồn hoặc là trước khi nó
bị quá tải hoặc trước khi nó bị thiếu
hàng chẳng hạn.
Mình làm một cái bài toán dự báo.
Giá trị.
Mà cái đó nó cũng chỉ là một dự báo nói
chung luôn á.
Chứ không phải dự báo nhu cầu xong rồi có
phân tích thiếu rồi lại dự báo dự tùng dự
báo tồn kho nữa các em.
Thí dụ,
các em làm một cái bài toán về kết hợp
giữa dự báo và khi nó dự báo giá trị đúng
không? Và dự báo cái giá ở đó,
thí dụ mà nó âm có nghĩa là bị thằng bị
thiếu.
Đi du dù có cái hưởng đó thì nó lại là bị
tồn kho quá nhiều thì với mở mà cái đó
mình sẽ đặt cờ cảnh báo thôi.
Chứ nó có cách biệt đâu, nó là 1 quá.
Nếu mình thảo luận là chọn là cái lý
tưởng này nha em.
Gi.
Dạ còn gì để nhóm em nhận em thảo luận.
Nếu mình những máy ta những 4 đúng không?
Và nhóm 4 con.
Ở câu 2 like những bóng này.
Rồi tiếp theo, nhưng cuối cùng chính em.
Rồi nhóm 4 có thể tắt màn hình kem thảo
luận cập nhật lại đi.
Dạ,
cô thấy màn hình chia sẻ của em chưa ạ?
Rồi thấy rồi, em trình bày đi.
Dạ thì nhóm em là làm về công ty phát
hành sách Fahasa ạ thì nói ngắn gọn thì
công ty Fahata là một.
Công ty chuyên về bán sách on of và nhập
khẩu xuất khẩu sắt.
Dạ em xin lướt qua phần thông tin lịch sử
và quy mô với cơ cấu tổ chức để đến với
phần giới thiệu dự án luôn ạ.
Dạ thì đầu tiên,
cái dự án của tụi em là đầu tư nền tảng
ứng dụng tích hợp và nền tảng dữ liệu cho
hệ thống bán lẻ đa kênh Hợp Nhất FASA.
Với cái mục tiêu là dùng AI để cá nhân
hóa các trải nghiệm đọc sách và dự quá
nhu cầu và tối ưu luân chuyển hàng hóa
cùng với những báo cáo kinh doanh nhanh
chóng.
Thì cái vấn đề mà tụi em sẽ giải quyết ở
cái dự án này đó là.
Fahata hiện tại cái hệ thống nó chưa hiểu
được và phân tích được những cái sở thích
của cái khách hàng giống như là khách
hàng hay đọc truyện hay là khách hàng hay.
Tiệm sách về học thuật thì nó chưa làm
được.
Thì tiếp theo đó là về nó chưa ờ phân bổ
sách.
Đúng khu vực và thời điểm,
ví dụ như những mùa nhập học thì.
Sách nên được phân bổ về những cái chi
nhánh ở gần trường học.
Ờ
Và khi mà đã xác định được cái thời điểm
và cái khu vực hot thì.
Khi mà không xác định được những cái đó
thì doanh nghiệp nó khó xác định là đầu
sách nào,
nó sẽ có nhu cầu cao để mà phân bổ hàng
hoặc là lập kế hoạch kiểm soát,
kiểm soát tồn kho thì nó dẫn tới là.
Những nơi có nhu cầu cao thì lại thiếu,
còn những nơi có nhu cầu thấp đó nó thì
nó lại thừa.
Ở cái vấn đề tiếp theo mà tụi em muốn
giải quyết đó là.
Sử dụng AI để chăm sóc khách hàng.
Cùng với những cái nhân viên thay vì hiện
tại là chỉ dùng nhân viên thôi.
Mục đích là.
Nhân viên thì làm việc tắm tiết một ngày
thì khi mà có ai ai thì có thể là 24 trên
240.
Và.
Từ đó cũng có thể là phân tách ra cái
hành vi của người dùng và cũng có thể làm
hài lòng khách hàng ở một mức độ nào đó.
Và cái vấn đề cuối cùng của em muốn giải
quyết đó là.
Dùng AI để phát triển cái báo cáo phân
tích trên hệ thống nghiệp vụ tốn nhiều
Cái này là mình đang đầu tư hạ tầng trước
mà cái em đầu tư hạ tầng xong rồi em mới
thời gian.
phát triển hệ thống phần mềm.
Không phải cái hệ thống của ai,
hệ thống nào nó cũng chịu nổi đâu cái em
giả sử mấy cái hệ thống bị ai mấy cái em
đang nghi hiện tại á.
Với số lượng người dùng lớn á,
hạ tầng của em chưa đầu tư nổi,
làm sao mà có thể xử lý được với cái số
lượng người dùng cao và các cái tak phức
tạp được?
Nhưng cô mới cho các em làm theo trình tự
để các em hình dung rõ hơn là bây giờ
mình sẽ đầu tư hạ tầng trước.
Xong rồi mình qua bài thực hành thì mình
sẽ đầu tư phát triển hệ thống phần mềm
ứng dụng công nghệ mới thì lúc đó các em
muốn dựng công nghệ AI vô cái hệ thống
phần mềm của mình. Thì mình.
Trình bài sau
Dạ.
Vậy nhưng mà nhóm em sẽ đầu tư vào cái 2
lớp 9 đó là.
Apple in teration letform với lại data
letform.
Với 2 cái hạng mục chính là.
Lý do vì sao mình phải đầu tư 2 cái lớp
đó.
Và tại vì để em.
Mình chưa,
mình cái vấn đề hiện tại của em và nhu
cầu giải quyết của các em tới đang bị cục
bộ vô cái phần mềm á,
nó chưa phải là cái gốc,
nó chưa phải là định hướng phát triển
chung của công ty.
Hoặc là vấn đề lớn của công ty mà dẫn tới
mình phải cần đầu tư 2 lớp năng lực này.
Kem ứng dụng luôn.
Dạ.
Cái dự án mà mình không nói rõ đó là
người ta, người ta rất là liền luôn á.
Tôi sẽ không có phí tiền đầu tư vô mấy
cái dự án thu ra dự án mà nó không đem
lợi ích gì lớn cho tôi đâu.
Tại khi mà gọi là đầu tư cơ sở hạ tầng mà
chi phí nó sẽ rất là cao.
Thì cái tầm nhìn của mình phải rộng.
Còn cái dự án phần mềm thì nó sẽ chi phí
thấp hơn,
Dạ.
thì mình sẽ đánh vô cụ thể một cái dự án
phần mềm ứng dụng cái gì đó.
Nhờ vậy, để cái này tụi em sửa lại.
Để nhóm mình, nếu mình thảo luận lại,
nếu mình thảo luận là cái này á.
Còn cái việc ví dụ em muốn ứng dụng trí
tuệ công nghệ thứ mới là ở đây em toàn là
Dạ.
công nghệ trí tuệ nhân tạo đúng không?
Cho quy trình gì đó.
Ở đây các em chọn quy trình gì?
Và ở quy trình chăm sóc khách hàng với
lại những cái dịch vụ ở bên trong cái hệ
thống doanh nghiệp ạ.
Thì.
Ứng dụng như trang sách sẵn sàng đúng
không?
Dạ.
Chọn một cái là gel để mình chọn một cái
bài toán cụ thể.
Dạ.
Ví dụ chăm sóc khách hàng,
ứng dụng QR cho chăm sóc hàng mình làm
cái gì?
Ứng dụng xây dựng chatbot hay là xây dựng
hệ thống khuyến nghị.
Giờ trách bót ạ.
Ừ thì mình miêu tả,
lúc đó miêu tả kỹ như một cái.
Dạ.
Ừ, nhóm mình cô cũng highlight luôn nha.
Dạ dạ, tức là cái.
Cái dự án thì mình sẽ là tập trung vào
cái của nó là chatbox đúng không cô?
Đó là dự án phần mềm nãy giờ mắc nhóm
trước báo cáo em có nghe không?
À.
Như vậy em hiểu ạ.
Cái cơ sở hạ tầng là các em đầu tư,
các em phải tưởng tượng, thí dụ bây giờ.
Mình sử dụng các CPT hoặc là cloud nhiều
rồi đúng không?
Các em tưởng tượng một cái hệ các em muốn
cái hệ thống phần mềm đó đâu phải mình
xây dựng cái hệ thống phần mềm nó có thể
chữa tải được cái hệ thống với cái lượng
số lượng dùng mà cái hệ thống lớn như vậy
đâu. Các em muốn phát triển đầu tư,
các em phải đầu tư hạ tầng trước,
em phải có cái trung tâm dữ liệu.
Rồi em phải có đánh em phải liên quan tới
kết nối mạng này,
em phải liên quốc em phải tìm hiểu tới
các vấn đề an ninh bảo mật thì người ta
mới dùng cái dịch vụ của mình và cái đó
em đầu tư xong hết rồi, bắt đầu mình mới.
Phát triển cho cái nền tảng cho hệ thống
phân bị ứng dụng người dùng ở đây,
nó mới chạy ổn định được.
Còn cái thí dụ đầu tư hạ tầng của em mà
chưa có thì nó sẽ không có phát triển
Nh.
được đâu.
Dạ.
Tôi ví dụ các em ở đây,
ví dụ như giả sử như Vasan ta muốn nâng
cao cái khả năng ứng dụng công nghệ thông
tin lên đi và thì mình có thể khảo sát và
có nói là cái lớp về.
Dữ liệu lớp năng lực và dữ liệu của các
lớp năng lực và bảo mật của công ty nó
còn yếu và nó chưa đáp ứng được cái sự
phát triển của các hệ thống mới hiện tại
và khi muốn dụng công nghệ mới,
nó chưa đáp ứng đủ nhu cầu.
Rồi bây giờ mình sẽ tăng cường 2 cái lớp
dữ liệu của cái lớp mạng lên chẳng hạn.
Tăng tranh người dùng truy cập.
Ví dụ như vậy và trong 2 lớp đó và em
quyết định đầu tư.
Dạ.
Giả sử là phần cứng nó chưa có hoặc là nó
chưa đủ thì em sẽ đầu tư mở rộng thêm cái
hệ thống server.
Rồi đầu tư thêm các cái lớp năng lực khác
tùy theo thành phần em chọn giống như cái
bảng nắm xạ hồi nãy em muốn chọn cái nào
thì em chọn.
Dạ.
Mà từ giả lập ra,
sau đó là kem mới phát triển cái vô phần
mềm thì vô cái bài thực hành,
phần mềm thì em chọn một cái ví dụ như em
muốn xây dựng một cái chatbox.
Ứng dụng AI chuyên cho xử lý ngôn ngữ
tiếng Việt.
Để hỗ trợ cho khách hàng của FASA hoặc
chuyên vô cái lĩnh vực các dịch vụ của
FASA đang đầu tư luôn.
Để cái chất bốc nó cũng chuyên một về một
thứ chứ nó cũng không có đa di năng gì
lắm em.
Mấy cái mà như thằng Chativity GerB Night,
hệ thống lớn lắm luôn,
nó mới có thể trả lời được multic tác nha.
Còn thường thường cái chất bóc quá là.
Khi mà mình triển khai là mọi người sẽ
giới hạn cái phạm vi nó, thí dụ,
cái trách móc mà hỗ trợ cho cái hệ thống
pháp luật đi thì nó sẽ chuyên về tra cứu
tài liệu pháp luật và trả lời các câu hỏi
về pháp luật thôi. Chứ hỏi khác,
nó trả lời.
Chưa có rành đâu tại mình chưa có trend
tới.
Ví dụ như vậy thì nếu mình tính là cái đó.
Tới cái buổi báo cáo tiến trình được giao
cho tôi sẽ có kỹ lại hơn em.
Dạ.
Dạ dạ vậy để nhớ sửa lại ạ.
Mình cập nhật lên drive trực tiếp trên
loa là được.
Dạ.
Thôi vậy,
bây giờ tôi cho nhóm các nhóm 3 sữa ha
các nhóm highlight tới buổi tiếp theo
mình trình bày lại rồi cô dạy bài tập mới.
Nếu mà có thời gian còn không thì tới
buổi sau.
Được vẫn có chuyện gì em.
Hỏi kỹ hơn về cái phần mà bài thực hành
đó con thì để em chia sẻ mô hình của em.
Cô đã thấy màn hình của em chưa?
Rồi.
Dạ, nãy em là nhóm số 5 á cô,
nhóm em có chọn.
Đầu tư vào lớp 4 và lớp 5 thì và cụ thể
là tụi em chọn các thành phần là phần mềm
quản trị với bảo mật ấy con.
Thì cái trong bài thực hành của mình của
quê em là tức là ở các thành phần ở lớp
nào thì sẽ chọn cái công nghệ cụ thể ra
của lúc đó của thành phần đó đúng không
cô?
Và khu chưa hiểu ý em muốn lắm mà sao.
Đấy là cái phần mà chọn cái cái công nghệ
mà.
Công nghệ mới hả?
Công nghệ mới là cô không có giới hạn như
công nghệ mới đâu. Cô không có giới hạn,
Ví dụ.
nhưng mà thí dụ em đã chọn 2 cái lớp 4 có
lớp 5 rồi á.
Thì mình cần chọn cái danh sách công nghệ
trong lớp.
Ví dụ dưới đây của em có lớp dữ liệu đúng
không?
Thì các em có thể chọn tìm hiểu về các
công nghệ mới trong cái lĩnh vực về dữ
liệu.
Vậy khoa học dữ liệu.
Dạ, ví dụ,
dạ ví dụ như là ở lớp 4 là app và
eteration,
platform á là ví dụ như là ở thành phần
là phần mềm thì tụi em sẽ trình bày về.
Ở ví dụ như là cái công nghệ là viết mình
làm mobile làm web hay là làm API xong
rồi ở thành phần quản trị thì mình có
dùng cái công nghệ về gig hay gì đó.
Về monitor.
Không em cái đó là công cụ thôi,
đó là công nghệ,
Rồi ở bảo mật.
nhưng mà các em đang sử dụng vô đây,
nó như là một công cụ thôi.
Kem sử dụng ứng dụng công cụ kỹ thuật để
sử dụng thôi,
các em đâu có triển khai đâu.
Kem và nếu uống mấy cái gì công nghệ bên
Gins đó là các em đem về,
các em chỉ gọi IBA cái em xài thôi chứ em
đâu có triển khai nó đâu.
Còn cái bài thực hành mà cô kỳ vọng á.
Là kem đi tìm hiểu, em làm chủ công nghệ,
em tìm hiểu một công nghệ mới và kem tự
triển khai nó luôn,
ví dụ giống như các có nhớ hồi nãy làm
chat box đúng không?
Thì không phải gọi IBI chấp bốc có sẵn mà
các em sẽ nghiên cứu về tự mình triển
khai nó luôn.
Cái mô đồ xử lý aniwi đó luôn.
Và em hiểu về quy trình nữa.
Ở đây là kem chỉ cần hiểu về quy trình và
kem xử lý có thể tự bi hội setbox dành
cho tiếng Việt,
dành cho đúng lĩnh vực mà em đang làm.
Nếu em chọn ở đó.
Dạ,
ví dụ như cụ thể là tụi em chọn cái quy
trình cụ thể là để lấy là nhóm em chọn là
wheystation là có nhiều mảng như là cầu
lông rồi.
Ở quán cà phê quán net rồi gì đó cô thì
tụi em muốn có chọn một quy trình là đặt
xuân hay là đặt bàn ở trong một cái nền
tảng thống nhất luôn á con.
Thì tức là tụi em sẽ là.
Đặc sân, đặc sân,
đặc bài lớn nhất thì chung cơ sở dữ liệu
làm được thôi.
Em định áp dụng công nghệ mới gì để tăng
trải nghiệm người dùng?
Dạ tức là ví dụ như là khách hàng xài cái
mobile app thì em sẽ trình bày là ra là
em triển khai làm cái mobile bán công
nghệ gì?
Rồi cái back-end phía sau là ví dụ như là
em chọn docknet hay là java để mà.
Cái đó là kỹ thuật phần mềm thôi em,
đó là kỹ thuật phần mềm thôi.
Các em vẫn chưa hình dung cái công nghệ
mới của cô nói hả?
Hình.
Thứ nhất là cái bài thực hành thì cô
khuyến khích là nó đi theo trong cái lớp
năng lực của mà các em đang chọn bên Quân
đồ án.
Giả sử ở đây các em có lớp về dữ liệu và
cái lớp liên quan về app đi.
Thì mình có thể tìm hiểu về các công nghệ
liên quan về quét và app và công nghệ mới
và do mình triển khai.
Ví dụ,
giống như các công nghệ về khoa học dữ
liệu thì các em có thể sợ các từ khóa về
công nghệ mới, về khoa học dữ liệu.
Giống như mình nghe nó là khai thác dữ
liệu lớn thì trí tuệ nhân tạo này mà
cinenin này. Nipanin nè.
Hoặc là cái app về web3,
blockchain chẳng hạn thì các em có tìm
hiểu về các công nghệ mới đó và các em
nếu mà các em chưa rành thì các em coi
các em không biết shard hoặc là xác định
nó luôn á,
thì các em có thể lên danh sách tìm hiểu
về cái danh sách các công nghệ nổi bật.
Việt Nam mình đang muốn phát triển,
chẳng hạn cái em chọn trong cái danh sách
đó một công nghệ mà các em muốn phát
triển thôi.
Thí dụ,
giống như khi mà đưa ra cái dự án đầu tư
bộ khoa học công nghệ đi,
các em nhanh nhất bỏ khoa học công nghệ,
các em coi, bỏ khoa học công nghệ,
thì nó đang kêu gọi dự án đầu tư á là sẽ
đầu tư để phát triển các công nghệ lỗi
mới nổi bật hiện tại và công ta list.
Các công nghệ lỗi luôn rồi đó,
em có thể chọn một công nghệ lỗi để các
em tìm hiểu.
Và mình ví dụ,
nếu công nghệ lõi đó ứng dụng thì nó sẽ
giúp tăng cái trải nghiệm người dùng hoặc
là giúp cải thiện cái quy trình nào chẳng
hạn.
Các em chọn một cái bài toán trong và nó
có thể ứng dụng như công ty và các em
chọn.
Cũng được không nhất thiết ở đây,
cô hay chờ rộng luôn không nhất thiết
phải vô 2 cái lớp năng lực đây của các em.
À,
tức là cái bài thực hành là nó không có,
không có phải là đi bám sát vô cái.
Lúc đầu là cô được yêu cầu bấm sát,
nhưng mà các em không rành quá thì các em
chỉ cần vô lĩnh vực đúng công ty của các
em thôi.
A.
Thí dụ bây giờ công ty của em chọn là
công ty gì?
Dạ.
Công ty trong ngành công ty các em chọn
là công ty trong lĩnh vực gì?
Và giải trí con và có để giải trí thể
theo.
Giải trí.
Đúng rồi thì giải trí dễ thao,
thí dụ các công ty bên thương mại vậy đó
thì bây giờ các công nghệ lỗi nếu ứng
dụng trong lĩnh vực thương mại thì thường
thì người ta hay ứng dụng cái lĩnh vực gì?
Nếu mà các em không rành,
các em có thể search.
À,
mình có danh sách các công nghệ lỗi rồi
đúng không?
Thời em có hỏi là các cái bài toán khi áp
dụng các công nghệ lỗi đó trong cái lĩnh
vực giải trí hoặc là trong lĩnh vực sản
xuất hay là trong cái lĩnh vực giáo dục?
Chẳng hạn.
Thì nó thường dùng nó hay là cái bài toán
gì thì các em có thể chọn mua bài toán để
Dạ.
các em làm thôi.
Dạ rồi, em cảm ơn cô.
Thì các em có thể coi.
Giả sử cái bài thực hành của mình,
cô đang cho các em giả lập giống như các
em đang viết xuất minh sinh dự tiền,
kinh phí dự án của bộ khoa học công nghệ
á.
Có các dịp bỏ học này thì nó có các dự án
dạng ứng dụng hoặc là các dự án dạng
nghiên cứu cơ bản,
các em hay chọn một bài tốt để mình làm.
Nhạc.
Nên cái phần này là cô chỉ đánh giá để
các em hiểu về một cái công nghệ lỗi mới
và nếu mà mình muốn tự triển khai cái
công nghệ lỗi đó thì mình phải có các
bước triển khai nào.
Và nếu mà mình triển khai thành công rồi
thì nó có thể áp dụng vô một cái lĩnh vực
cụ thể nào trong công ty của em.
Quan chọn hay không,
thí dụ vô lệnh cụ thể nào thì vô ví dụ
giống như của em là lĩnh vực giải trí
thương mại chẳng hạn thì nó nó có thể ứng
dụng vô cái quy trình nào trong cái lĩnh
vực này,
giải quyết được vấn đề gì trong cái lĩnh
vực đó là được.
Và cái công ty của mình trong lĩnh vực đó
thì nếu mà cái bài toán nó giải quyết
được cái vấn đề trong lĩnh vực giáo dục
đi đúng không?
Thị trường đại học nào cũng áp dụng được.
Các em hình như ví dụ,
các em bạn nào mà chọn bên ngân hàng thì
ví dụ nó là áp dụng được cho lĩnh vực tài
chính thì em là ngân hàng nào thì nó cũng
áp dụng được hết.
Nếu mà nó cái bài toán công nghệ lõi đó,
em đang giải quyết một bài toán trong
lĩnh vực giáo dục thì trường đại học.
Nào cũng có thể áp dụng được.
Trong lĩnh vực giáo dục của đại học,
chẳng hạn như dự báo,
cảnh báo khả năng tốt nghiệp rất tốt
nghiệp của sinh viên đúng không?
Nếu mà em giải quyết được cái bài toán đó,
những cảnh báo sớm để thông báo cho sinh
viên cho phụ huynh.
Cho cố vấn học tập về khả năng rất tốt
nghiệp của sinh viên.
Thí dụ mới học năm nhất thôi theo cái dữ
liệu hiện tại em có thể cảnh báo là cả
đánh giá được khả năng rớt tốt nghiệp của
sinh viên á thì mình đưa ra cảnh báo sớm
để nhắc nhở sinh viên phải cải thiện lại
cái thái độ học tập của bạn đó.
Rồi cảnh báo cho.
Gia đình đi gia đình biết là coi bạn đó
coi bạn đó có quyền bất thường gì trong
quá trình học không hay là bạn đó đang có
hiểu gì ham chơi chẳng hạn.
Cố vấn học tập cũng lớn thông tin sớm và
có thể nhắc nhở sớm chẳng hạn.
Thì khi mà em làm được bài toán đó rồi
thì trường nào cũng áp dụng được.
Rồi ly sao.
Ly.
Ờ dạ cô ơi,
nhóm em đó cô là em làm về pha xa á.
Thì em đang giả lập là cái pha xa nó đã
đủ năng lực về các phần cứng và các lớp
Ừ
nền tảng rồi.
Và em đang đề cập tới là em sẽ nâng cấp
nó lên.
Cân bằng 2 cái lớp là ớt lớp app
integration platform và data platform thì
app thì em ứng dụng công nghệ là Kubernet,
còn app thì em.
Không phải em lát hai, nếu em đã đầu tư,
em xác định 2 cái lớp đó là em phải bày
đồ án môn học là em phải đầu tư các thành
phần em. Trong bản ánh xạ bữa trước,
những bữa trước tuần trước đã sửa rồi đó.
Dạ thầy thành phần của á panteration á
thì nó sẽ là get với ABI và cái công nghệ
là kopennet ấy anh tới cái cô.
Đầu tư rộng hơn em, cái bảng đầu tư,
cái bảng ánh xạ, cô nhớ có rồi mà em.
Dạ là phải đầu tư nhiều hơn một công nghệ
đúng không?
Đầu tư toàn đầu tư trọn vẹn nguyên 1
thành phần đó hoặc là nâng cấp trọn vẹn
cái thành phần đó,
ví dụ như phần cứng hoặc là cái phần quản
trị bảo mật cho cái lớp data của em.
Dự án đầu tư là dự án cách đầu tư nó phải
rộng vậy đó em.
Dạ vậy thì em vẫn phát triển dựa trên 2
cái lớp app và lớp data platform được
đúng không cô?
Được được.
Rồi vậy hả,
ghét chúng về sửa tới buổi tiếp theo thì
có thời gian thì cô sẽ sửa đầu vào,
còn không thì mình.
Tôi sẽ xếp một cái buổi báo cáo tiến
trình sửa sao.
Nếu không có vấn đề gì nữa thì buổi học
mình kết thúc ở đây hết em.
mấy cái.